bonjour et bienvenue sur probablement
aujourd'hui j'accueille alexandre techno
prog de la chaîne qui porte le même nom
alexandre est également docteur en
informatique théorique et
post-doctorants actuellement à l'école
polytechnique fédérale de lausanne et il
est également vice-président de
l'association française de
transhumanisme toujours alexandre jours
alors on va commencer par une petite
question pour essayer de connaître
est ce que tu peux a parlé un petit peu
des temps de parcours est fait en partie
par georges avait étudie le ms paris
saclay ou qui s'appelait une escale ans
à l'époque puis j'ai fait une thèse en
informatique théorique puis là je suis
post doc à le pfl et c'est tout pour le
moment
ils tombent parfois un petit peu
philosophique donc là là c'est pour par
rapport au transit humanisme expliquant
l'évolution de tes idées au cours de ces
dernières années
ouais alors la chance ça ça va être un
petit peu long à expliquer parce qu'en
fait je suis je suis allé chercher un
petit plus loin avant d'arriver au
transhumanistes distrayant en a au moins
deux heures par le problème c'est que
quand je parle de ça ça me fait passer
pour quelqu'un d'un peu fou un peu comme
unique bostrom quoi il parle de super
intelligent c'est alors que j'ai essayé
d aller progressivement tues tu me dis
si si je pars trop en vrille alors voilà
le point de départ c'est une question
qu'on se pose tous en tout cas beaucoup
de gens c'est qu'ils aient le sens de
notre existence peu papa de mon
existence en particulier mais de quel
est le sens de la l'existence de
l'humanité en général c'est peut-être
tout le monde se pose pas cette question
mais pas mal de gens cela pose en tout
cas
en tout cas ça me semble être une
question est importante quand est ce que
tu te les poser une application vraiment
voir baveur 14 ans makeba oui ça m'a
pris plusieurs années avant d'arriver au
transit monisme mai valait pas que tu
connaissais pas du tout le
transhumanisme franchement n'ont
pratiquement pas gai et de paris ce qui
t'intéresse est question les réponses
que tu as trouvé à 14 ans ou 14 ans
jusqu'à 18 ans jeu
continuer mon raisonnement donc bien sûr
il dirait qu'il y avoir des réponses un
peu nature mystique mais si on est
plutôt agnostiques rationalistes mots
comme pas mal de gens qui vont écouter
j'imagine va pas forcément trouvé ça
satisfaisant et parce que face et on est
plutôt agnostiques rationalistes on va
avoir tendance à se dire que au final si
l'humanité existe c'est juste le produit
du hasard et de la nécessité n'est pas
vraiment de grands buts derrière donc du
coup la question se transforme en quel
sens donner à l'existence de l'humanité
quel sens nous mêmes pouvons nous donner
pro activement à notre propre existence
et déjà un premier truc qui est quand
même important de préciser c'est que
c'est déjà ça c'est pas mal d'être
heureux toutes choses égales par
ailleurs va faire être heureux que
malheureux moi j'ai des opinions un peu
extrêmes et a été débridée mais va même
une fois qu'on est raisonnablement
heureux on va dire c'est quand même pas
entièrement satisfaisant c'est là où je
suis pas totalement utilitariste parce
que si j'étais totalement utilitariste
et ben l'optimal si j'ai pas peur
d'aller vers des trucs un peu
transhumanistes fois ce serait de se
mettre des électrodes dans les centres
du plaisir du cerveau comme dans cette
fameuse expérience avec le rat qui
appuie sur un bouton et d'être une
espèce de comex tactique avec un grand
filet de bave sais pas je sais pas si
beaucoup de gens elle aurait envie
d'aller vers ça mais je connais des gens
qui auraient envie de dire ça mais c'est
une minorité
vidéo att comme ça c'est sûr jones au
crac insatisfaits comme un messie mais
ensuite il faut idéalement il faut mieux
être socrates satisfait comme ça on peut
avoir le beurre et l'argent du beurre
je ne pose pas le bonheur à ceux dont je
vais parler ensuite il ya pas que le
bonheur est validée devise est
absolument que le bonheur et rien
d'autre me semble assez insatisfaisante
peut-être que ces biais cognitifs qui me
font dire ça mais au quelqu'un je tiens
à céder committee feu
et donc de lui donc qu'est ce qui sera
important à qui ne serait pas le bonheur
c'est très difficile à définir c'est ce
que beaucoup de gens appellent on va
dire complexité mais le mot n'est pas
entièrement satisfaisant alors pour
illustrer salut seulement que j'ai
trouvé c'est de faire une analogie qui
n'est pas forcément satisfaisante et que
certains vont même trouvé un peu
offensante c'est de comparer un humain à
une forme de vie plus simple
bon allez je vais dire à un planton
parce que vous avez quand même un peu
quand je dis une mouche salaires mouchot
fob effet mirarchi entre les espèces
c'est pas bien donc la plante on s'est
suffisamment coupe donc les gens ne
soient pas trop choquer cours de se
poser la question qui est pas très bien
défini mais intuitivement
est ce que vous préférez est ce que tu
vois les tu préfères être un humain ou
un plan dont je me dis que si jamais on
trouve que les plans de temps c'est
important ça autant de leurs 15 juin des
baleines sont un génocide ministre et à
chaque instant passé énormément de
plantes qu'il faudrait mieux manger des
bananes que des connus crevettes
mais voilà si europe de bière j'ai posé
cette question à pas mal de gens et de
façon amusante certaines personnes
effectivement préférait être un planton
humain bah il faut il faut respecter les
préférences de chacun et de toute façon
le transhumanisme pourrait les aider à
devenir des plantons si cette personne
ne souhaite est ce que tu penses que les
gentils réponse à leur répondre vraiment
veut dire honnêtement adresses ont
réfléchi ou est ce que c'est juste pour
essayer de défier le transfo nice mon
fils parce que ça paraît bizarre fans de
préférer train plantant un bas peuvent
forcément varia sens pas que les gens
qui répondent à leur répondre dans cette
optique et c'est plutôt des gens qui
pratiquent ils pourraient même aller
encore plus loin et ne verrait pas de
problème à être une pierre par exemple
donc cherché une espèce de star ac 6
bouddhiste extrêmement poussée ou un
truc comme ça
ok pas pour pourquoi pas mais cela dit
la majorité des gens préfèrent quand
même être animal qu un planton parce que
bon ok lui plante on ne va pas avoir de
tournois existentielle ça c'est un point
pour le planton mais en même temps il ne
va pas avoir il ne va pas savoir
apprécier la beauté d'un théorème de
matous
la poigne d'une musique d'un paysage
donc pas vraiment être malheureux mais
il va pas vraiment être heureux d'une
manière intéressante non plus donc du
coup même si être humain ça implique des
parfois plus malheureux que le planton
toute chose considéré ça me semble quand
même mieux d'être un humain en plus
intéressante que du coup les gens qui
préfèrent être implanté qu'un humain se
serait par rapport à ça aussi vous
peut-être basse et 5 courant qui
s'appelle utilitarisme négatif parce tu
connais les gens qui n'aiment vraiment à
la souffrance qu'ils considèrent que
éviter la souffrance à une priorité
moral absolu sur nos achats et du
plaisir va même si on peut subit très
heureuse et très heureuse et curé un
jour on se cogne à un orteil dans une
porte basse à annuler tout le bonheur de
la vie il y avait un bouquin qui est
sûre ça qui se passait c'est ça a été
écrit de façon un peu ironique mais qui
s'appelle better never have been congrès
ne vaudra ne jamais avoir existé à une
vidéo de dirt belleville par le média
aussi malchanceux puisque on part un peu
transhumanisme la loire des fondateurs
du mouvement qui s'appelle david spurs
était un philosophe britannique
il se considère comme utilitariste
négatif et ça fait un peu peur est dit
que si il existait un off switch de
toute vie consciente dans l'univers ils
appuieraient dessus ouais mais
heureusement comme comme cette
possibilité n'existe pas et que arriver
à ce résultat de bandera de la
souffrance il va visages et des méthodes
plus douces comme rendre les gens plus
heureux
là on peut être d'accord c'est l'escale
menaces et perturbe heureusement cette
opinion là n'est pas majoritaire dans le
moment transhumanistes et mes jeux mais
c'est intéressant parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de discuter avec lui
plusieurs fois et udine où on se dit
mais c'est complètement débile que ce
qui ce qui n'est bien en fait il est
extrêmement doué pour défendre ce point
de vue de manière très rationnelle crap
sera posée façon logique la galette
il a un point bas en partie fait qu'on
lui donnerait pas vouloir la complexité
vraiment ouais beaucoup d'importance oui
mais idéalement à remplir l'univers de
bono extatique et qu'elle donne de
l'importance et au bonheur vous allez
qu'il existe le même et la plus courte à
n'y va plutôt s'intéresser à des trucs
comme la souffrance animale qui est un
sujet extrêmement compliqué à la fois
les animaux domestiques second rêve
et puis les animaux sauvages qui sont
encore plus que j'utilise david d oui
justement ça c'est une petite parenthèse
je ne vais gagner ce chemin on avoue on
a quand même toit plusieurs heures j'ai
compté deux heures minimum format
actionnaires en fait c'est vrai que si
on se soucie vraiment à fond de la
souffrance animale
au bout d'un moment on peut se dire ok
peut-être qu'on peut agir sur les
animaux d'élevage mais il reste qu'il y
ait des lions qui vous faisait zèbres
dans la jungle et quand j'étais à ces
jeunes de l'aide d'une vidéo youtube de
deux zèbres qui se faisait dévorer
vivants par une dizaine de vienne
pendant 10 minutes d'agonie atroce
épouse espèce de cris qu'on n'imaginait
même pas possible et ça pétarade c'est
clairement pire que tout ce que j'aurais
un animal d'élevage et ses données
stockées en particulier où il se faisait
demander des membres et vivent très très
lentement a que les yankees
c'est bien qu'ils jouent avec les est
pratiquement si vraiment la souffrance
animale ça semble bizarre d'exclure sa
des problèmes quoi mais pourquoi pas je
te dire ouais ça c'est la nature faut
pas y toucher
du coup c'est la race a cédé un peu de
vérité que certains appellent
extrémistes qui voudraient aussi agir
sur le monde sauvage pour brandi un peu
en épouvantail mais
sans forcément dire qu'il faudrait faire
ça je trouve que c'est quand même un
problème qu'il est important de
considérer que c'est un problème se pose
beaucoup à d'autres on attend d'en
savoir beaucoup de gens y pensent avoir
une vision assez simpliste de la nature
en disant des fondateurs son t1 pm biais
naturaliste mais voilà nature n'est pas
tout joli est il jamais la souffrance
animale est quelque chose qui quiconque
ou cherchent à éviter ça va à l'encontre
potentiellement de pas mal d'autres
choses qu'on défendra par rapport par
exemple plus diversité - trade offre un
compromis à trouver entre certains
certaines formes de souffrance animale
de la sauvage et ces questions
difficiles en tout cas oui au brésil que
dans l'idéal les layènes pourrai manger
un robot zèbres qui inquiète la
présidente de sucre découpant l'âge de
vote à l'ag fait une parenthèse je
reprends mon raisonnement qui est assez
loin il a une fin alors on essaie
raisonnement le pronom logique ça passe
moins un toit du passé bah plus ou moins
oui sauf que j'avais pas le dernier
élément du peu ce qui est un peu le
transhumanisme inquiet on voit donc du
coup et donc je reprends cette idée que
si on considère que même juste
subjectivement que moi je préfère être
un humain kaplan tout se sait pas c'est
même pas une hiérarchie moi c'est juste
une préférence personnelle
on peut se dire dans ce cas pourquoi
s'arrêter en si bon chemin pourquoi ne
pas vouloir si cette complexité ce
gradient de complexité du planton vers
moi il ya de la valeur bah pourquoi
s'arrêter à l'huma pourquoi considérer
que c'est un truc que finale et pourquoi
ne pas chercher on allait là je suis
dans la pure théorie pour l'instant par
exemple imaginer avec un humain avec un
cerveau beaucoup plus complexe qui
auraient des expériences artistiques
scientifiques ou émotionnelle infiniment
plus complexe à côté desquels nos
expériences se ressembleraient à des
expériences de un peu un peu merdique
et ça c'est pas pour atteindre un stade
beaucoup de gens vont dire que le but du
transhumanisme c'est de créer le
posthume à outrance cumin et puis qu'on
a fait ça c'est bon la saisie vois
plutôt ça comme une espèce de direction
quasi infini où j'ai dit quasi parce
qu'il ya les limites physiques de
l'énergie disponible dans l'univers par
exemple mais on peut aller très très
loin dans cette direction comme une fois
qu'on serait devenu quelque chose de
beaucoup plus complexe il n'y aurait pas
de raison de s'arrêter en bon chemin
parce que c'est cette entité plus
complexe pourrait avoir exactement le
même raisonnement et je veux dire est un
peu petite parenthèse parce que les
laits pour me sentir un petit peu moins
seul dans ses réflexions un peu folle
j'ai cité un peu un argument d'autorité
qui le philosophe under samberg du
future of humanity institute qui va
bientôt sortir un livre un peu sur ces
questions qui s'appelle grande futur ce
qu'on pourrait traduire par futur
grandiose cette question c'est est ce
qu'on pourrait faire avec toute la manne
de cool avec toute la matière et
l'énergie de l'univers en voici
supposons qu'on ne rate pas la
singularité ça c'est un peu le super
intelligent ce coup passe avec succès de
l'étape de la singularité what happens
next et laurent voir là je cite la
manière dont il décrit seront son livre
à venir c'est ce que à notre battu tu
joues tu vois le jeu des trombones temps
quand elle avait fait une vidéo
parce qu'ici nous étonnons pas vu ces
vidéos de l'est qui s'appelle des
trombones encore des trombones les voir
cela elle faire le jeu il décrit son dif
comme c'est comme le jeu des trop bonnes
mais à la place des trop bonnes y aurait
deux multi titre omnium qui prennent ces
substances astra qui décrirait l'optimum
de des choses auxquelles on accorde de
la valeur avec toute l'énergie semis
dans l'univers qui que ça ne donne pas
mal d'énergie devrait faire pas mal de
trucs c'est une idée du potentiel de ce
qui peut être fait
ouais si on n'a rien maîtrisé sa porte
par exemple vous pouvez l'imaginer c'est
pas des cerveaux de la tête d'une
galaxie truc
complètement vertigineux comme ça c'est
assez vertigineux donc pour sexuelle
soit 5h sandberg il a fait il est
interviewé sur les tisanes avoir une
interview tellement cool que a été
divisé en de faire deux épisodes trop
cool parce que la période est trop
longue et c'est quelqu'un de 1,15 off de
doctor qui est qui c'est très
intéressant
je connais pas encore le livre mais je
sens que je vais y jeter un oeil
il n'est pas encore sorti mais à mon
avis il veut mettre encore quelques mois
à sortir elle sera a priori édité dans
la même boîte édition que super
intelligence avec le prestige académique
universités d'oxford par dessus ces
considérations un peu un peu folle le
premier abord mais ça ça a bien marché
avec cpnt johnson sur des sujets je
pense qu'on a eu on y reviendra plus
longtemps mais sur ce genre de sujet
c'est la question on part de la
conclusion de des raisonnements de ces
philosophes
il s'est très vertigineux et ça peut
faire vraiment peur ça peut donner
l'impression que c'est vraiment fou mais
pour essayer de rentrer dans un ancien
faut vraiment y aller pas à pas et
chaque étape du raisonnement est faux
pas trop juger le résultat final avant
de comprendre un peu la logique bien qui
arrive assez souvent
alors juste en plus que tu insistes pour
que je parle du mois du préfet d'alors
en gros des thèmes de réflexion à
l'époque pas en gros qu'on avait 14 ans
j'ai découvert le philosophe nietzsche
et je trouvais ça trop trop destroy trop
votre base à son bon jeu mais
aujourd'hui je recommande absolument pas
de lire parce que en gros pour faire
simple mélange philo et poésie et
aujourd'hui je trouve que c'est vraiment
un truc à proscrire absolument à la
poésie c'est très bien mais si vous
voulez perdre un fils de la poésie
philosophique pourquoi pas mais si on
veut réfléchir correctement à des
questions philosophiques je pense qu'ils
aient si on introduit de la poésie
dedans mais ce que de se tromper de
poésie philosophie mais la philosophie
politique ça passe pas mais je suis
plutôt converti à l'économie
monsieur fidèles c'est un parfum va dire
pourquoi pourquoi est ce que les
hôpitaux étiquette parce que c'est une
usine à billy cognitif faire très très
attention et surtout je sais c'est aussi
lié au fait que je remarque que pas mal
de gens qui ont des mauvais argument
contre transhumanistes vivons importance
a formulé ces mauvais argument dans le
cadre de grands discours très
prétentieux crap on peut avec des grands
mots les grands principes et leurs
discours c'est parce que dd chant
lyrique c'est tout souvenir issa sarr
empêche de réfléchir
clairement pour faire 13 rega faso ne
pas être séduit par pardon à connotation
des mots ou la douche formulation
rhétorique des choses essayer de se
concentrer vraiment sur les arguments
qui sont proposés et ça a commencé il ya
beaucoup de lyrisme mélangés à des
arguments on a tendance à prêter plus
attention aux belles phrases que vos
arguments et une solution ccc d'éviter
un petit peu ses auteurs parce que c'est
très difficile en fait de courir ce
point lui stéphane typiquement sur le
transhumanisme il ya beaucoup de gens
vont dire que ça nous déshumanise
déshumanise fait une petite vidéo là
dessus le problème c'est que quand il
dit ça il commence à faire une espèce de
chant lyrique sur quel sur l'humanité
avec un grand écart à showtime en
majuscules si vous éliminez majuscule
enfin turquie on entend la majuscule et
du coup c'est dommage parce que ils font
leur petit poème lyrique où il
s'interroge pas vraiment sûr vous font
qu est ce qu on appelle oumar et essaie
de définir de façon la plus rigoureuse
et surtout pourquoi on trouve ça
important et qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait
préserver de ça et qu'ils seraient
souvent des réflexions beaucoup plus
intéressante
alors il faut pour reprendre le cours de
mes histoires
donc là où est donc anza avait 14 ans
j'avais découvert
niche que maintenant je fais pas dire
que moi s'il faut dire que pratiquement
que je renie complètement sa vidéo off
mais je retiens quand même une idée je
trouve toujours train d'être
intéressante s'est développée dans le
bouquin ainsi parlait zarathoustra je
crois à la ligne a limité les gens
peuvent venir vu juste le les pros
micheline des bouquins parce que c'est
là dedans que s'est développée que c'est
l'idée que un but pour possible pour
l'humanité ce serait non pas évolué pour
atteindre un objectif donner ce sera un
petit peu de l'idéal platonicien d'un
espèce de convergence vers à faire une
espèce de l'idée de perfection mais
plutôt le but
enfin le but ce serait le fait même
d'évoluer que ce serait le gradient
d'évolution c'est un espèce de quête
infinie d'évolution en commun sur connie
je définis de façon un peu lyrique mais
en même temps ça c'est difficile de
faire autrement à son époque parce qu'il
y avait aucune considération
technologique à l'époque et déjà c'est
un but qu'on peut sans aucune
considération technologique on peut
poursuivre dans le cadre d'une vie
humaine
par exemple en se cultivant cultivant
bas où on rend son expérience de vie
plus complexe
je vois par exemple en faisant des
macros avancer ou en faisant de
soulaines et stx et messi ont
expérimenté des trucs de combiner des
expériences bas on peut déjà avancer
vers cet idéal
oui ça c'était un petit peu mon point de
vue à l'époque mais ensuite on peut se
dire ok on peut faire pas mal de trucs
dans le cadre d'une vie humaine mais on
va vite être limitée par le fait que
notre cerveau est compact et dans une
petite boîte crânienne qui le fait qu'on
vit au final 90 ans a l'air beaucoup
mais
au final quand je pense qu'on arrive à
90 ans se dit j'ai fait que amis
gardienne de ce que j'aurais pu faire
que j'aurais trouvé intéressant sans
même parler des trucs qui sont pas
encore inventé qui vont après mois le
futur donc nous avons des limites
biologiques
quand je dis diniz s'est pas forcément
avec une connotation négative mais nous
sommes limités dans notre potentiel pour
reprendre des termes de nietzsche par
nos limites biologiques
du coup pourquoi ne pas aller au delà de
c'était le titre d'un livre d'un
philosophe maintenant par un
scientifique une crypto transhumanistes
miroslav radman qui travaille sur la
biologie du vieillissement qui il
préfère dire qu'il n'est pas
transhumanistes à mon avis un peu pour
des raisons de comme quand on sort un
livre qui s'appelle au delà des limites
du logis c'est quand même un petit peu
transhumanistes l'idée que deux bords
après je vis a pas de moment précis où
je suis vraiment hâte et réussir
transhumanistes ça a été progressif par
exemple en lisant ce livre
ok c'est vers 14 15 ans c'était moi la
chronique
ouais là là là quand je lis ce bouquin
c'était magique
c'était une première année à annonay sq
[Musique]
ou à 10 18
j'avais deux ans d'avancé 19 j'ai
ensuite bas j'avais entendu parler de
cette association française
transhumaniste en fait d'après faut que
j'ai entendu parler du mot
transhumanisme c'est un ami qui m'avait
parlé et c'était comme une espèce de
sectes californienne de gens qui veulent
se greffer sibra un peu genre à elle
j'ai pas accorder plus d'importance que
ça et là il y aurait justement jeu en
essayant de me creuser ces réflexions
parce qu'au bout d'un moment je
commençais à trouver des philosophes
comme mix france franchement à
satisfaisant pour même un petit peu
agaçant je me disais du coup j'étais pas
dire en crise philosophique parce que
c'est un bien grand mot mais j'ai
cherché d'autres pistes mais et violent
je vais commencer à m'intéresser à cette
piste un peu transhumanistes et s'y
intéresser de plus en plus et au final
vous pour pour aller dans l'ombre pour
acheter de ceux de sunrise un peu une
réponse qui me semble assez
satisfaisante voire même tracé nice
faisant tout problème du sens de la vie
on n'est pas obligé de partager mais
c'est une proposition que je fais c'est
de se dire l'humanité ou au moins une
partie de l'humanité qui sera intéressé
par tout ça pourrait chercher à créer
des formes de conscience mais je mène
dans un premier temps qu'ils seraient de
plus en plus complexes par exemple notre
effet ça pourrait être déjà essayé de
vivre beaucoup plus longtemps en bonne
santé pour avoir bien davantage
d'expérience pour augmenter nos
capacités cognitives ou capaci même
probable nos capacités émotionnelles
voit même une capacité à ressentir le
bonheur parce que là je préfère une
parenthèse là dessus c'est il ya des
gens qui sont génétiquement moins
heureux que d'autres
du coup c'est là que naquit sont plus
heureux que d'autres et on pourrait
continuer à imaginer créer des dans le
futur des humains qui y voient une nappe
l1 et d'onyx est polt notre niveau de
bonheur au repos qui serait beaucoup
plus élevé que notre niveau de bonheur
aux remous actuels ce qui serait
détaillé investir donc aujourd'hui il ya
de la recherche en biologie qui a montré
que quelques certains gènes prédisposant
à la place étaient plusieurs c'était il
y ait des gens qui c'est pas cool pour
eux mais qui est génétiquement on est
prédisposition à la dépression
loto des valorisations
au cas où atan cognitif négatifs qui
vont entraîner du malheur bien sûr après
il ya toutes sortes de thérapies pour
ainsi compenser ça mais comme en sport
il ya des gens qui sont plus chanceux
que sur ce plan que d'autres parce qu'il
y aura je sais pas ce qui s'est vérifié
mes rondeurs sanders dean phrase qui a
été beaucoup cité c'est à y avait une
extraordinaire li hai hédonique 7.5
écoutant un peu le sourire
c'est assez intéressant mais ça peut se
dire qu'on va pouvoir ce que tu proposes
du coup de modifier génétiquement la
nage
moi je proposerai un voeu mais à papa
m'a par exemple des tapis de fleurs ce
temps j'ai parlé tout à l'heure à qui il
restera dit qu'elle pense qu'on devrait
faire pour imaginer que créera
progressivement des humains qui seraient
de plus en plus heureux que des régimes
un peu mais ce qu'ils voulaient créer
des humeurs de plus en plus forte
je pense que c'est pas super intéressant
mais en si on veut essayer d'augmenter
le bonheur ça me semble un objectif
plutôt humaniste qui serait de ne pas
forcément heureux dans un sens un petit
peu à bestiaux mais heureux dans le sens
un peu comme ces gens qui sont très
exalté qui ont plein de projets qui sont
toujours super excités qu'ils sont
pleins d'idées ils sont très créatifs
520 direction très positive
on gagnerait allait être dépressif donc
ça c'est un plat forcément dire
expérimenté un état de bonheur permanent
continue parce que parce qu'on a tous
des périodes basses kodachrome mais à
une certaine époque je pensais que le
bonheur c'est un petit peu un jeu à
somme nulle dans le sens où le saut sur
une vie humaine on subjectivement on
aura autant de malheurs que de bonheur
mais je pense de moins en moins que je
pense d
vraiment il ya des gens qui ont quant à
eux vivent au rythme des gens qui vont
naître au soudan pendant le génocide ce
truc comme ça qu'il faut avoir une vie
varie de plus ou beaucoup
au final on se mettrait à personne de
vivre ce genre de vie est mort seulement
il est gentil vont avoir des vies
craquera exaltant très excitante
par exemple ne serait ce qu'un chercheur
scientifique qui était alors son métier
qui a plein d'idées mais on laisse et
c'est plus lié à l'environnement
ouais ça sera un petit peu plus bas on
peut voir ça comme un motif y ait un
petit peu parce que les gens vont du
lean pas mal sentir un malaise par
rapport à ça parce que ces impressions
de modifier un petit peu la nature de
l'individu pascal et j'en attends ça
associé un petit peu l'adn à la nature
de la vie voir l'essence du vivant sont
ils c'est déjà pour modifier depuis ses
intérêts c'est important de voir ça que
le voient l'adn c'est pas un truc puis
j'ai maintenant je pense qu'il ya un
intense à donner une valeur très
symbolique fall adn et l'adn humain et
que si jamais on modifie bas ont détruit
un petit peu cette nature humaine chez
schwarb en même temps mais on a tous des
aînés est assez diversifié donc par
tournoi un peu plus ou un peu moins
diversifiée pas le leur on a comme en a
pas tous le même adn partant de là ça me
semble moins choquant les modifiés ne
serait ce qu'un peu notre adn et je
pense que du goût de la tuyère comptable
de douma pcd bien aimé voir de façon de
penser qu'ils ont à dire le premier je
pense que c'est vraiment le s2 de biais
du statu quo de ne pas changer le cours
naturel des choses quelque chose comme
ça et puis l'autre pièce est à on a
tendance à donner beaucoup de valeur à
ce qui nous semble naturel du
naturalisme et je sache on pas penser
aux gens qui quittent et good par et
j'imagine que c'est un petit peu ça qui
qui va faire qu'il souhaite mal à l'aise
l'année l'un des trucs qui m'a aidé à
relativiser ce malaise s'était alors
comment formuler ça en gros les humains
sont je pense que les choquer personne
en disant quand même que les humains
sont globalement espèces étaient plus
intelligente sur terre et c'est lié en
partie au fait qu'on a une grosse boîte
crânienne ce qui n'était pas le cas des
homo erectus qu'on va nous ancêtres ont
fait de la paléontologie et pourquoi
c'est le cas en fait c'est apparemment
ce serait vraiment lié à quelque chose
de train une espèce de bazar de
l'évolution un peu absurde il ya
plusieurs explications possibles mais en
gros c'est qu'avant on avait une toute
petite boîte crânienne et d' énorme
mâchoire pour déguster de la viande crue
et or pour des raisons qu'on va assurer
qu'il n'y a pas forcément d'accord donc
c'est un certain vous dire que c'est
parce qu'on a appris à cuisiner de la
viande avec du feu du coup c'était plus
facile à mâcher du coup d'une atrophie
des mâchoires me disent que c'est une
espèce de rage et une mutation génétique
qui a causé une atrophie des mâchoires
un truc qui a priori diminue nos chances
de survie dans un environnement naturel
hostile mais elle les fait accidentel de
ça c'est que ça a décompressé la mode
crânienne et a permis d'avoir un plus
gros cerveau ce qui au final était un
avantage sélectif mais inversement cette
taille de cerveau est limitée par le
fait que parce que choisir que cissé
c'est positif d'avoir une grosse boîte
crânienne ben pourquoi ce qu'on appelait
des cerveaux énorme comme dans star trek
c'est parce que si on a un cerveau trop
énorme
les bébés souris meurent à la naissance
où es-tu sa mère à la naissance en cours
nous on est limité en taille de boîte
crânienne par rapport à l'accouchement
alors on va être en passant une des
raisons pour laquelle l'accouchement
humain est peut-être plus de l'heureux
que pas mal d'espèce je peux pas
attendre des chevaux bas c'est parce que
les bébés humains ou intra gros crâne et
que non mais on est à la limite au-delà
de laquelle les bébés mouraient s'il
avait un cran plus haut mais du coup
c'est cette limite cette taille de crâne
a été au final c'est parce qu'elle est
déçue qu'elle a été fixée de manière
hyper arbitraire par l'évolution et du
coup n'a rien d'absolu
mâle de trois réflexions que je me suis
attelé c'est que si tu as déjà entendu
parler aussi des thérapies pour pour
pour des enfants qui sont qui sont
sourds à la naissance pour certaines
formes de deux maladies sont souvent on
peut les soigner du coup du pied se
remettre dans des délais peuvent se
remettre
ce maître du tout à réussir à écouter
mais il ya un mouvement que chez les
personnes sourdes qui qui va un petit
peu à l'encontre de ça en me disant on
va la personne est né comme ça fait
partie un peu de notre communauté de
gens sourds et des parents qui
s'opposent à rome un chouchou mais un
peu ce débat parce que déjà il y avait
chaque année où pratiquement chaque
année il ya un gros truc transhumanistes
internationale qui s'appelle france vise
une espèce de colloque de trois jours
avec tous les mouvements transhumanistes
dans le monde et à il y en avait un qui
avait été organisée en france en 2014 ou
comme on est en france on aime bien les
valides et contradictoire du coup il y
avait un débat sur le thème de la
surdité de la surdité de la surdité
volontaire en habitant des orateurs
mais ce sont des robots géants qui
représentaient ces orateurs
et oui en effet en effet le débat était
assez tendue
c'est à dire le winner il ya un
philosophe qui écrit un bouquin est là
dessus qui est assez proche de
l'association transhumanistes qui se
passe comment
non ça me fera changer maintenant qu'il
y avait aucun qui a écrit un livre qu'on
peut retrouver sur google qui s'appelle
loges de ma fille bionique parce qu'on
va les passions mais sa fille et une et
soul elle a un implant cochléaire s'il a
fait le jour de sa fille d'un implant
cochléaire marsan billard donc il ya
beaucoup réfléchi à cette question de la
surdité la surdité volontaire ou
et déjà la motivation des sceaux
volontaire c'est que c'est pas tellement
de dire que c'est bien parce que c'est
naturel parce qu'ils acceptent ils
acceptent très bien qu'ils élèvent en
entendant par ailleurs c'est plus que
l'idée de préserver la communauté saône
parce que le fait de ne pas entendre a
amené les sourds à développer une
culture sourde par exemple le langage
des signes et du cou avait effectivement
c'est imaginons qu'on est un remède qui
pas cher du tout comme j'aurais vaccin
qui puisse se permettre de ne faire que
y ait plus aucun enfant sourd à la
naissance donc quelque peu entre eux des
mecs plus aucune excuse
on pourrait être source c'est vrai pour
effet que la culture sourde
disparaîtrait ça serait que du vent bon
moi je suis pas avoir en parler parce
que en tout cas pour l'instant je n'ai
pas de preuve d'avoir un enfant mais mal
de parents aiment bien l'idée que d'une
certaine manière
leurs enfants vont être un peu comme
hugo et être un peu comme euh bah ça on
est sûr ça veut dire ça sera mieux ce
serait de leur point de vue ce qu'ils
étaient sourds parce que leurs enfants
seraient plus proches d'eux
effectivement resté serré en fonte et
souris à mettre effectivement plus
proche d'eux que si les entendants et
qu'il ya un entendant qu'il ya des
parents sous ça va créer une distance
que du coup par exemple la vie des
parents sourds qui chercha par exemple
qui font de la procréation médicalement
assistée
un couple de femmes lesbiennes au son du
coup elles ont elles sont débrouillés
pour choisir un donneur qui selon son
profil génétique maximiser vraiment la
chance que l'enfant à naître soit soir
oui je crois qu'il est effectivement
mais souvent ce que je peux dire c'est
que oui c'est un sujet extrêmement
touchy et je n'ai pas de réponse je ne
pense pas qu'il ya quelque chose de même
ordre on dort pas avoir ce gène de
l'hellénisme d'ivoire
cette question n'est des parents qui
sont pas particulièrement où je pense
qu'il ya un gros avantage là dessus
c'est que cette perte progressive parce
que je me souvenais pas soit on est
sourd soit on et entendants mais ça
rapporte beaucoup de sens d'être un
petit peu sous auquel lacie on imagine
une augmentation très progressive de
génération en génération
ce que même même des parents qui sont
malheureux a priori veulent le meilleur
pour leurs enfants qu'on ne connaît pas
beaucoup de parents qui disent je suis
dépressif suicidaire j'ai envie que mes
enfants soient des processeurs arm et
oppressif is here peut-être pas mais il
ya je vais pas nier calme ne suis pas
une culture autour de du spleen d'être
une culture de l'indignation de quelque
chose un peu way qui pas pour le coach
rémois gêné de combattre cette culture
que la culture soit parce que c'est
d'avoir un petit peu deux dossiers ont
proposé à des parents vraiment raspes
l'inique d'avoir un enfant qui serait à
l inverse super positif excité là c'est
vrai que cette loi crée une distance un
peu comparable à suhr pas souvent mais
si ces jeux rend propose juste d'avoir
des enfants qui souhaitent un peu plus
heureux qu'en moyenne pas pas forcément
gérant déjà mais heureux à 100% mais
juste un peu moins malheureux je pense
que l'immense majorité des dépenses se
redresse à leurs enfants indépendamment
du fait qu'on soit pouvons compter
manipulation génétique si on posait
vraiment ça comme une question purement
théorique que vous souhaitez que vos
enfants soient plutôt plutôt banal
je pense que la plupart des parents que
leurs enfants soient plus tôt
veux tu peux peut-être avancer sur les
questions voilà ces deux questions en
une heure qu'est ce que tu dirais à tous
moi du peu assez du qui avait 14 ans qui
dénie tout seul on avoir un rapport avec
le temps et humanisme qu'est ce que tu
dirais que c'est un pack très spécifique
mais je dirais de grosso modo ce que je
dis de façon ultra résumé dans ma vidéo
qui s'appelle arrête de temps devenu un
vrai c'est une vidéo dont je suis déjà
plus résumé d'idées pour les antilles
les ide ont pas vu y est c'est que je
pense avoir trouvé au g10 avait une
méthode pour résoudre totalement le
problème de l'ennui en tout cas qui
marche sur moi je sais pas si ça marche
sur d'autres personnes si ça m'arrivait
assure moi c'est ça semble souvent très
très con mais ça sera en ir vraiment 3
astuces génial pour perdre 30 kg entre
un jour des vidéos des satisfaits pas
beaucoup parce que ça donne à peu sur ce
film là alors que pour moi ça lui
vraiment une importance simple c'est un
changement très important d appliquer
cette méthode ça en gros de se dire déjà
de base si on s'ennuie pas de problème
ensuite si on commence à s'ennuyer là
que faire bien a commencé par faire un
espèce de noailles storming de trous
vaguement intéressant et constructif
qu'on pourrait faire ça peut être des
trucs à la con alors faire la vaisselle
parce que c'était bien quand la
vaisselle reste trois jours dans le vrai
mais les trucs un peu plus constructive
comme lyrique lire à livre bien écrit un
livre ou bien à conquérir le monde
ça peut être des toqués du tout que plus
banal autre qu mégalomaniaque mais on
peut avoir une liste de projets comme ça
qui serait donc il serait intéressant de
consacrer du temps ensuite leur mettre
une note datée réduit à dix là encore ce
ne sera pas parfait comme comme ranking
mai
c'est mieux que de choisir ainsi qu'au
hasard qui sera peut-être clairement pas
le meilleur et d'une fois qu'on a fait
c'est storming cette petite notation à
choisir les trois ou quatre items parmi
les mieux notés de la liste que par
exemple ça peut être dire à un grand
livre un peu intimidant genre super
intelligence de type ostrom bien faire
du sport mais la faire une nouvelle
vidéo c est à vous d'être à travailler
dans ses recherches en maths
du coup tout simplement pas faire par
exemple c'est juste un exemple possible
dix minutes de la première activité
digne de la seconde dix minutes de être
troisième et un faire un cycle comme ça
en tout cas depuis que j'applique que
cette méthode un peu à la con je ne dis
pas que j'ai une productivité optimale
mais d'une part je ressens absolument
j'avais jamais l'ennui
moi je pense même pouvait pas non plus
pour notre raison et d'autre part même
si c'est pas forcément le petit bal
optimale jeu chaque jour la pression
subjective en tout cas d'avoir avancé
dans mes dans le bidule et du coup de
m'endormir relativement satisfait ouais
c'est un tatouage et des gros problèmes
dans globalement bien oui je pense
beaucoup manqué plupart des gens mais
j'ai quand même des problèmes par cette
puce clés au fait que le sens super mal
d'addiction mal de trucs et d'internet
twitter notamment
et que j'ai c'est de lutter contre ses
addictions j'ai installé une application
sur mon téléphone pour bloquer les
applications la nuit et que du coup on
comprend les ses empreintes ces
applications sont bloqués c'est juste je
pense que c'est juste une transition de
gaspare c'est juste une condition les
parages
je ressens l'envié d'y aller et du
coucher un peu frustré et il ya un petit
peu empoté ennuis à ce moment là mais
j'essaie de en avant d'autres
applications pour écrire des scripts
pour pour lire des livres
et je pense que petit à petit facho
content je suis vraiment content d'eux
il ya des petites perles d'ennuis comme
ça de frustration mais du coup tu fais
c'est transition de dix minutes à chaque
fois qu'on fait on essaie tout est
vraiment pas forcément de dix minutes ça
peut être moins un an ou plus mais
l'idée c'est que si je me dis je vais
faire cinq heures de telles activités
cesser trop intimidant j'ai pas osé
commencé alors que du coup on peut se
dire ok ça corse 3 timide on va disons
une heure est ce que c'est encore trop
intimidant je suis un algorithme c3 est
évident et je dois utiliser le temps par
deux jusqu'à avoir un temps qui est
suffisamment plus intimidant pour vous
je puisse commencer activités en sachant
que au final le plus important c'est de
commencer parce qu'ensuite ça va tout
seul que ça permet de vaincre la langue
ouest de commencer un truc en se disant
ou là si je commence ça je m'engage à le
faire pendant cinq heures et parle par
exemple cinq heures de lecture de nîmes
bostrom c'est un peu chiant parce que si
on dit juste là ok déjà je vais lire
trois pages
pour commencer je dis pas qu'il faut
lire entre emplois créés en trois pages
mais déjà les retenir trois postes c'est
pas intimidant du tout que ça dure
présentant au pire c'est super chiant et
j'ai checké facebook ensuite pour et
benjamin papa et pour lire les livres
avant j'avais déjà mais pas m 2 de
difficultés à lier enfin je pense que
papa m'aime pas mal de gens ne lisent
pas trop parce que souvent pas mal de
livres qui sont intéressants sont aussi
assez chiant et laborieux un jour j'ai
réalisé ce truc du coup mais alors c'est
pareil ça va leur couper ça a l'air
complètement débile que je vais dire
mais au final dire un livre c'est lire
une page de livre puis tourner à la peur
clairement même un livre à de philo
assez chiant dire une passe ça va tout
le monde peut si je te dis ligne pages
de livres là tout de suite maintenant ça
va parrainer des bleus coup de gens du
coup il suffit juste de faire ça sans se
poser de questions une fois qu'on est
arrivé à la fin de la poche de se poser
exactement la même question puis au bout
d'un moment on a lu un bouquin ne
peuvent se rendre compte du coup j'ai eu
aucun mal à lire des bouquins énorme
un type dans ses pensées un mais bien
deux hommes à moto
barney stinson sdi 300 premières étapes
courir et appâts deuxième étape n'a
marché se fera pas et marché c'est bien
d'un algorithme wade et à sa propre aux
gars que m'avait dit un vieux monsieur
si tu as peur de faire de faire dit pas
fait juste un peu je pense que ce
progrès la cour a eu pas mal
d'influencés je pense à un truc qui
arrive très souvent c'est que quand on
imagine une tâche
notant une blonde tâche de moderniser
l'image
il s'appelle et d'autres trucs on sent
que le truc est très complexe et très
difficile et on a du mal à se lancer et
des fichiers a juste à la première étape
du truc qui désire on verra le sujet de
la suite après puis recommencer ça
permet de se lancer en teck et puis en
fait lorsqu'on fait pas mal d'opérations
comme ça hop a posteriori une fois qu'on
l'a fait ben on se rend même pas compte
qu'on n'a pas fait toute cette distance
sur son sens en ce sens et fort
subjectif 500 et forcée il ya quelque
chose de très fort si je regarde toutes
les vidéos que j'ai fait est aujourd'hui
sur ma chaîne mais s'est construit tout
ce que j'ai fait mais bon jour le jour
bombe à une vidéo de plus par semaine
alors venu il ya une analogie qui me met
pas mal de psychologiquement là dedans
alors c'est quand j'étais petit j'avais
un gros bouquin business des records 98
un truc comme ça quand il y avait un
record
moi j'ai pas vérifié si c'est vrai parce
que ça semble un peu flou mais en tout
cas j'ai eu envie croyez à l'époque que
c'est un monsieur qui avait une capacité
assez incroyable qui est de digérer dû
faire ça il peut y avoir digéré
tant de grammes de fer par jour mais du
coup il s'est fixé des objectifs un peu
à la cour du roi
j'ai mangé un caddie puis une voiture
puis un léger un cockpit d'avion mais je
suis passé à côté des fossatois quand
même bizarre mais est simplement ce qui
en faisait sait que chaque jour je crois
que frau mais qu'apparemment il a acheté
un une carlingue d'avion avec sa fortune
privée dont elle même dans son jardin
puis chez chaque volet on a fait un
petit bout qu'il mettait dans sa bouche
puis laval est la quantité maximale
pouvant avaler chaque jour et
recommencer le lendemain et au bout d'un
moment ils avaient fuit de plusieurs
années il a fini par rapport aux
bouchers un avion juste pour leurs
cornes et du coup de stylet sursis si on
se dit je vais devoir manger un avion
ces voix c'est terrifiant mais par les
et de terreur mais c'est pareil pour
n'importe quel projet un peu ambitieux
alors que c'est le site au moment juste
quelques grammes d'eau par jour ou d'un
moment notamment la nature voilà là on
s'était pas s'il me bat à l'époque fois
que j'étais plus jeune j'ai abandonné
beaucoup de projets mais maintenant
pratiquement pas faim en abandonne quand
je les juge plus intéressant même mais
par exemple j'ai toujours pas abandonné
le fait de faire des vidéos youtube mais
[Musique]
la botte de kruth était liée au fait que
j'avais eu beaucoup de sollicitations
irl pour faire des différences et
compagnie je n'en rajoute un peu un peu
frustré parce que j'avais envie de faire
la vidéo sur lui mais peut par exemple
pour le fait que par exemple pour
prouver quand vous êtes l'idée d'y jouer
je le lis des livres uniquement quand
soi quand j'attends le bus quoiqu'en
chez soi confie dans le bus dans le
rapport quoi ce qui mine de rien fait
pas mal d'heures de lecture par semaine
ça fait à peu près à un ou deux gros
livres par mois
du coup pour pour les livres bas pour
reprendre la méthode en soit tout à
l'heure
non pour rédiger un algorithme qui
commande et que comme une certaine
personne qui remet ouvre hall ce qu'est
ce sport qu exiger plus aucune prise de
tête c'est un des génies des livres
intéressants à lire je vais dans ma
liste
ensuite quand j'ai fini le livre que je
que j'étais en train de lire je vais
dans ma liste bon jeu mais une note à
tous les livres qui n'ont pas encore une
note
puis je prends le livre qui est nommé
noté et puis je me suis sur ma liseuse
électronique puis je y lit
tranquillement page par page de ses
saisons puisque ainsi nous concerne nous
d'électronique et que je mets du texan
sera très gros parce que j'ai une
mauvaise lubasa devrait en être des
poches très petit et très faciles à lire
un bouquin les lauriers puis vallée puis
trafic vers la page sombre a calmement
puis jeu suivante puis la suivante la
suivante et enfin je n'ai pas regardé
des bouquins à c'est assez énorme comme
ça et puis je passe tranquillement au
suivant un son sans stress et du coup
j'ai résolu le problème de la lecture
avec un âne goût à peu près optimale je
pense parce que j'ai toujours
l'impression d'être en train de me dire
leaf qui est le meilleur livre selon ma
liste de préférences subjective un truc
qu'elle a fait et si j'ai pu lire à en
parler c'est le fait qu' il ya un peu
des creed 2 modes de pensée le premier
qui est un peu le mode
si au pdg de planifier d'avoir une
vision à long terme de concevoir les
algorithmes que l'on va suivre
et puis l'autre mode qui est vraiment le
mas 2 workers vous voyez où est ce qu'on
applique l'algorithme qui a été fixé par
le cio par le pdg mois et lens m'a un
petit peu en mode automatique comme ça
et en fait c'est pas forcément
désagréable c'est ça c'est productif
c'est normal qu est ce que tu dis aurore
que les deux sont pas incompatibles
parce que au final la limite où il a
effectivement pour certains projets il
faut un plan très complexe parce que
sinon ça va ça va pas le faire
mais faire se plantera complexe c'est
une première étape du projet et
commencer à faire le ballon se plantera
complexe à la première étape de la
première étape du projet qu'on peut
appliquer la même méthode y compris pour
faire des trucs qui ne relèvent pas
directement de la même monnaie une autre
métaphore à la con qui m'avait qui qui
m'a pas mal d'influx et a influencé pour
aller vers ce mode de pensée c'est que
quand j'étais en master ii y avait je
faisais un truc un petit peu orienté
réseaux informatiques et puis il reprend
lettres des méthodes de routage
informatique donc que les paquets les
petits paquets d'informations on trouve
leur leur chemin dans le grand réseau
internet
il ya un truc qui s'appelle mpls je
crois que j'aurais pu lui expliquer
exactement ce que ces envois l'idée
c'est de se dire voilà je vais aller de
10 à une espèce de le réseau
informatique ans avec plusieurs routeurs
interconnecté donc il faut que je passe
par plusieurs routes heures pour arriver
à destination
il décède se dire ok là je vais aller me
destination c'est ça quelle est la
prochaine étape qui va me rapprocher de
plus je détermine le routeur qui va me
reprocher le plus du routeur finale j'y
vais une fois que je suis dans ce
deuxième round je me hockey qu'elle est
et je pose exactement les mêmes
questions et puis appareils de routeur
ou tu vas voir grand projet vous gagnez
le monde première étape que je fasse de
même muscle premier acte elle s'inscrit
dans la salle de muscu et une nature
raison de quelques quelles que soient
vos preuves et même s'ils sont
complètement fous il ya toujours une
première étape puis au final si on pense
en termes de première étape on sera
peut-être pas hyper optimisé comme
certaines personnes qui sont derrière
l'ultra productive mais en moi parce que
je pense que la principale raison qui
fait que les gens ont peur de se lancer
dans des projets c'est vraiment là le
fait de devoir le projet comme une
espèce de baleine qu'on va devoir manger
d'un coup du coup elle paralysée par la
peur elle devrait faire au final même si
cette méthode n'est pas optimale je
pense que pour beaucoup de gens ce
serait se serait déjà une amélioration
énorme d'appliquer cette méthode parce
que ça permet d'éliminer les angoisses
de le premier
un peu que je donne parfois des des gens
qui veulent se lancer sur youtube mais
qu'ils disent c'est très compliqué
youtube voir le son âge avoir un projet
assez énorme dans la tête alors que
c'est intéressant
youtube et j'ai vu deviner un petit peu
ttp un niveau apparaît tout à fait une
animation qui sait mieux au fur et à
mesure mais elle a fait se produit pas
beaucoup la route juste repoussés à
chaque fois le mandat première vidéo en
fait la première vidéo c'était juste
pour faire un essai pour voir ce que
cette donnée sur parce que ces dix la
première vidéo se questionner la
question j'ai été surpris population et
c'est vraiment la question que compose
le plus souvent on m'a posé des dizaines
des dizaines de fois voilà bah voilà ça
c'est un peu que je chante ligier
demande elle avait commencé à faire des
vidéos pour la même raison c'est qu'il y
en avait marre de me répondre aux mêmes
questions à quoi je vais faire une vidéo
comme ça je peux mettre le lien vers la
vidéo et c'est réglé
ouais je souhaite bon débat
d'après la presse et j'ai ça c'est une
critique que je peux faire moi même
c'est que niveau technique c'est la pop
beaucoup mais avancer même si j'ai
acheté un meilleur chrono dans ces mais
j'aime bien cette méthode a un petit peu
cheap parce que ça me permet de bien
découper chaque étape par exemple
l'égalité il est à écrire le script il
faut que c'est fini à l'étape enregistré
son il faut que ces filles avec l'étape
faire les images et c'est fini à l'étape
sa promise et les images avec le son
puis faire la description que notre
enseignement informatique
ouais je pense je pense que c'est
c'est assez y ait effectivement le fait
d'avoir fait par exemple d'une thèse en
informatique
mon but c'était de créer des petits
algorithmes de faire des preuves
mathématiques dessus ça pas mal
influencé ma manière de penser
ouais c'est de décomposition et puis la
quête de la simplicité c'est un truc
intéressant qu'on apprend en faisant
d'informatique il compte pas c'est une
autre question
une heure sur les trois premières
questions toutes les questions comment
tu t'en est en forme saas en général
bah je pense que pas de manière très
différente de toit ou doute la face et
des vidéos youtube des jeux et des
mutuelles très intéressante
ce matin je me sentais du meurtre à
procrastinateurs j'ai commencé la chaîne
qui s'appelle geography na ou simplement
extraordinaire c'est juste mais qui fait
d'une vidéo par pays par ordre
alphabétique en commençant par
l'afghanistan la journée à neverland
qu'elle allait il est un virus 5
millions d'abonnés entendre en partant
de afghanistan c'est pas mal mais à
savoir c'est si rien d'extraordinaire
mais ces boîtes apprend des trucs sur
des pays s'écouler rage et bien concerné
ce genre de contenu se reposera vient
aussi des vidéos et dans le même jour de
deux docks seven sur des vidéos de
géographie d'ailleurs il dit que
s'inspirer de géographie nawa part il
fait des vidéos récemment sur des laits
l'air aussi région par région
parce que c'est le rang et les régions
de russie c'est un truc que personne
connaît du coup bien consommer ce genre
de truc c'est un peu comme des chips
youtube maps en bois de pin et vidéo une
vidéo thank you for all monsieur fille
jade mentale 4 4 voilà je regarde toutes
les vidéos il ya après il ya des
podcasts
les compagnies mais en face corps
j'écoute pas mal de podcasts simplement
quand je marche dans les rues parce que
deux ans à attendre le bus qui permet de
lire des livres mais aussi à marcher
dans la rue sans rien faire d'autre que
marché du coup j'ai écouter des podcasts
sur baladeur mp3 mais je rends général
c'est plutôt aider des vidéos youtube
des vidéos de conférences que je vais
téléchargeurs mp3 pour écouter des
conférences sur nos transhumanistes ou
les trucs comme ça
ok on va papa mêmes algorithmes j'ai une
liste de trucs à écouter genre mais une
note et je télécharge communauté mais
que comme ma liste
comme pour les livres malice toute ma
liste grossi beaucoup plus vite que
j'arrive à l'agitée c'est une très bonne
chose comme ça je manquerai jamais de
trucs à l'écouté des il ya des gens qui
sont déprimés par l'idéal mais
j'arriverai jamais à tous chers à lire
tous les livres au japon avait dû
justement justement c'est cool parce que
de toute façon clairement on n'arrivera
pas à lire tous les livres réellement
rien mais même si on était immortel et
les leafs écrivent plus vite qu'on
arrive à les lire quoi que ce soit même
en vivant ce sens milan on n'arrivera
pas à dire toutes les allées mi temps
arrive ravir tous disent qu'ils ont été
écrits avant l'an 2000 par exemple n'est
pas parce qu'aux visites qui ont été
créés entre temps du coup partant de là
comment ça il faut accepter qu'on
n'arrivera pas à tout lire il faut dire
qu'ils ont mais ils ont les meilleurs
ils ont le meilleur puis on verra ses
intérêts santé et du coup ça c'est alors
ouais alors tout comme son addiction
c'est plutôt twitter moi j'ai une autre
addiction que j'ai quand même pas mal
réussi à combattre ces jours une news
mais aurait autant je ne vais pas aller
le genre consulter new york times le
monde et compagnie je pas trop sur fx
mais plusieurs fois par jour je
actualise la page coconews pouvoir ce
n'est pas un fou croustillant parce que
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec tes
réflexions sur la politique que ça
la politique quand on est des esprits
mais je suis totalement d'accord mais en
même temps c'est je trouve ça
divertissant mon cerveau reptilien truth
a envie de preuves des clercs la gare
nucléaire au pakistan mais tout comme ça
on aimerait c'est pas que j'aimerais moi
à suivre dans la même chance que de voir
en un sens où je trouve pas que ça me
perturbe à savoir ce à même ses limites
si je faisais ça juste une fois par jour
pas de problème que ces divertissements
du matin à quessoy part of the ways ce
qu'est ce qui est ce qui est un peu le
syndrome aller sur facebook
or qui a rien de nouveau mais continuer
ce qu est le fils est là comme google
news c'est que tu es comme pas super
souvent on va dire ça s'épuise on va
dire les cinq fois par jour et il y
avait des peurs de jl est beaucoup plus
que 5 fois par jour
mais du coup là je réduis à peu près
cinq fois par jour et autant d envoi je
croise pas plus que sa jolie justement
les highlights et je clique vraiment si
un truc super intéressant bien super
déterminant collector du que tu dirais
tu lis combien d'articles d'actualité
jeu j'ai surtout les en fait wall e
c'est un peu paradoxal que je dis ça
parce que je vais aussi créé pas mal
d'articles mais le formate d'articles ne
me satisfait pas trop en tant que
consommateur parce que c'est
c'est un peu un compromis pas terrible
entre le tweet et la vidéo youtube c'est
à dire c'est pas super loin à lire mais
du coup comme c'est pas super il y avait
tellement de centaines d'articles à dire
que ce soit
autant je peux faire une liste de vidéos
youtube intéressante à regarder autant
si je commence à faire une liste
d'articles faire la liste sera trop long
par ce serait comme faire une liste de
toutes les races et des séries vraiment
ans certaines jouent pas assez long pour
que c'est une chance d'avancer
du coup je plutôt que de lire des
articles ou pour se former je préfère
carrément c'est un sujet m'intéresse par
exemple l'intelligence artificielle
plutôt que lire des articles sur un
terrain de près sur l'intelligence
artificielle je préfère lire dira gros
nichons intelligence artificielle comme
ça qu'on livre
ce que tu t'organises dvd - de réflexion
jusqu'à déchirer sans dire j'en ai déjà
suffisamment a volontairement donc ça
par exemple sous la douche fasse
beaucoup de temps sous la douche parce
que je prends des douches pour
s'épanouir et patras découle souvent un
moyen plus écolo mais peut pas par
exemple les jeux par exemple quand je
lis un livre intéressant ça va l'amener
à certaines réflexions mais je me les
faits au fil de la lecture
c'est vrai ces défauts je m'arrête au
beau milieu d'une page dans le bus et
c'est vraiment très profonde
je pense un peu et puis le maire je
manquais de la station ça c'est le
chercheur ou alors rarement mais je peux
conduire ont un truc qui me stimule la
réflexion a effectivement penser ou qui
lors qu'il perturbe très souvent des
agences pas lu dans un livre parce que
toutes les deux je m'arrête merde c'est
vrai que quand je mets ça en balance
avec vous nos réflexions
j'ai par exemple qui me vient en tête
mais il joue ce n'est qu'il ya des
vidéos youtube qui sont tellement mind
blau quoi il ya peut-être la vidéo de
sur le dictateur 0.2 chose de
journalisme je fais plusieurs fois pause
dans la vidéo pour méditer sur le sens
de la vie c'est je crois la vidéo par
petites tranches d'une minute par de la
vidéo de cgpi grecque
je sais pas si c'était celle-là mais que
j'ai souvenir qu'il ya eu des vidéos ont
fait cet effet là que je suis regardé la
vidéo en petites tranches de 10 minutes
avec des longues pauses parce que word
et moi d'aider chine n'ont par exemple
je ne sais pas si je suis déterminé le
bouquin 1984 c'est parce que du coup il
y avait aussi une adaptation des
diffuseurs d'adaptation de 1995 il ya
aussi une adaptation de 1984 qui est
sorti en 1984 ouais on va alors lui du
livre on se trouve que c'est une bonne
adaptation du film dans le sens où du
livre pardon sens où elle n'a rien
d'extraordinaire c'est une adaptation
mais elle est aussi mind boulot que le
liffe c'est-à-dire aux électrodes trois
premiers garderie c'est super chiant
dire super intelligent ce dernier cas là
et quand ça s'est passé un truc quand
j'ai lu le livre
autant je m'étais forcément à lire les
trois premiers quarts tellement c'était
chiant et là j'ai tout lu d'une traite
tout est souhaitée
c'est jusqu'à ce qu'apparaisse comme un
épisode de black mirror
il tremblait et peut pas régler le
filmage et j'ai déjà lu le livre mais
samassa le film a refait le même effet
j'ai fait juste faire des pauses soit
ouais parce que dans les films à un film
que je suis pratiquement le seul à avoir
vu par millions que je connaisse un
mantra triste c'est le film get out qui
en gros c'est le meilleur épisode de
blake nord soit même si c'est pas un
épisode de blake no plusieurs c'est
amusant parce qu'elle est l'acteur
principal
c'est l'acteur principal d'un épisode de
black mirror ou avec des gens qui
pédalent pour faire de l'électricité et
qui est connu pour l'épisode de mec
marrant il ya une espèce d'expression
horrifié pour être correct et découvre
dans le film d'époque qui est la même
expression d'enrichir je peux faire
parler d'eux sans spolier mais c'est si
vous aimez black noir vous aimerez qui
était en jeu j'ai pu vérifier des
affirmations qui est que quand on
regarde un film dans l'avion on est
beaucoup plus émotionnelle
aujourd'hui ce film dans un avion dans
le noir où tout le monde dormait autour
de moi et j'étais émotionnellement
choqué que j'ai déjà repris leur poste
pour terminer du coup c'est pas une
solution pas très écolo c est à ce
moment que choisit les livres et hui le
peuple
j'ai dit j'ai dirigé suffisamment de
suggestions de livres qui m'arrive sens
que j'ai aucun effort à faire pour en
avoir assez que ont rejoint des 4,5 par
un paradis fiscaux je dis donc
manifestement d'exploser mois là elle
fait clairement plus de 2000 dit m
mais c'est pas un problème parce que la
lgo de free est linéaire que juste à
mettre une note et en la plupart du
temps je lis des livres 10 sur 10 ou 9
sur 10 parfois dans les périodes coach
de moi je commence à creuser dans ma
liste de huit sur dix ça c'est un peu
plus cher parce que huit sur dix ça
commence à être à la liste commence à
être assez longue bande et des fois ce
que je fais c'est que chaque ligne de la
liste à un numéro hors jeu génère des
nombres aléatoires les deux sens par
exemple pour en avoir une dizaine depuis
je fais non c'est juste un fichier texte
bakchich vous vouliez d'abord et déjà
été dit sur nice puis ensuite et 9 sur
10 plus de huit sur dix ses employés
mais c'est ça aussi pour plein de trucs
voyons voir pouvait pour les 6 6 dans ma
liste de huit sur dix il ya 210 ça va
être un peu chiant de tout ce qui
relevait donc ce que je vais faire c'est
jean sélectionné 10 ou pas au hasard
je fais un album ballade l'algo suis con
utilisent pour trouver le nombre maximal
de liste comprend le premier puis si le
suivant et meilleur jeu change sinon je
change pas quand j'arrive au bas de la
liste
j'ai eu le meilleur et comment tu notes
vraiment bas mais sûr comme j'ai pas
encore le lift peuvent pas ma note et
forcément il mangea certitude mais c'est
ce que je suis me semble intéressant est
ce que est ce que je il va m'intéresser
à lire mais pas par exemple sur le livre
the dictator ce que j'ai dit mais
j'avais une autre mode n'est pas super
élevé puis j'ai vu pas mal augmenté au
fil du temps ce que des défauts quand
j'entends souvent parler d'un livre
jarrige augmente sa note sa place dans
la liste
vous parlez pour the righteous mène à la
force que tu peux t'en parle j'ai
beaucoup augmenté sa note et puis j'ai
arrêté de lire parce que c'était
vraiment extrêmement intéressant
et est ce que tu cherches à la diversité
aussi
alors ça c'est peut-être une faiblesse
de la preuve c'est que j'ai pas non plus
m'amuser à faire une kenny catégorie des
séparés en catégorie parce que ce serait
trop laborieux mais c'est vrai que oui
bon si je reste en est dit par exemple 9
sur 10 et que j'ai déjà lu de livres à
la suite sur un terrain artificiel
même si on a encore un travaux sont
intelligentes et ficelles j'ai plutôt
choisir un truc sur un sujet un peu
différent histoire de varier un peu le
club allemand ce que je dis globalement
assez mariés donc ça va pas varier parmi
les sujets qui m'intéressent pas un peu
de son toit du passé lointain et papa
ton toi d'il ya 2 3 ans qu'est ce qui a
changé dans les idées ou les idées les
bardes et déjà voilà voilà de la moto
dont je parlais tout à l'heure je ne
l'expliqué pas encore ce bien voire pas
du tout ils étaient trois ans c'est
maintenant que je suis devenu autiste
nuke je ne connais plus l'ennui et les
souffrances causées à ccc si vous vous
ennuyez passé super six si vous vous
ennuyez ici cette méthode mais oui il ya
deux trois ans je me moquais d'eux dit
mme ostrom par exemple d'étudier
l'évolution en direct
bah enfin moi j'ai j'ai eu super
intelligent ce parce qu'un ami de
gestion transhumanistes
avait recommandé que paraissait aussi
comme l'hippodrome était l'un des
créateurs de l'association
transhumanistes mondial s'est fait
l'écho jeudi steve ostrava moins élevés
et donc j'avais su aller sans a priori
et sans vraiment m'intéresser puisque
c'est au sujet la beuze qu'on va pas le
faire que l'intelligence artificielle
m'intéressait mais juste comme ça je le
dis au début je me suis dit pourquoi pas
le sait ces trucs là c'est pas de la
pays ressentie ficelles que c'est dire à
mon opinion c'est vraiment ces espèces
de philosophes qui dans sa tour d'ivoire
et qu' il n'y a même pas fait l'effort
de lire l'article machine au renouveau
spécial mais pas ce que je veux c'est
vrai je crois qu'il est ce qu'il est
peut-être fait une version des télés
vivre après mais semble en tout cas que
la première version
c'était assez peu machine learning dois
encore pas du tout ça est lié date de
oui c'est vrai quoi ça 14 va dire un
petit peu de machines mais ça a été un
petit peu très peu à bic
le livre est sorti en 2014 auquel sont
aigris alors 12 - 2012 se moquer
ouvertement mais celle du coup c'était
juste avant le boom des chinois mais
c'est vrai que peut-être on n'a pas eu
la même version du 10 mai celle que
j'avais lu c'était un peu goodall
teychenné a reconnu qu'il ya
pratiquement voûté mais tu écris
l'algorithme manuellement
franchement ça me semble extrêmement
improbable que du coup ça me semblait un
peu innovantes comme préoccupation
surtout je me disais bon le spécialiste
en intelligence artificielle cdc vienne
le 15 c'est du bullshit donc urgence à
l'avis des experts
c'est moche et au final bages temps je
me suis aperçu que les gens comme vienne
le 15
j'en ai parlé un peu solitaire c'est que
com com du coup j'avais un a priori
négatif sur cette ligne de pensée qui
est celle du future of humanity stich je
voulais quelqu'un comme mannequin qui
commençait qu'elle sait sur facebook je
disais allez vas-y mon champion des
français et je m'aperçois mais en fait
du titre pas des bons arguments que les
arguments de de merde un peu de mauvaise
foi des attaques personnelles
c'est un philosophe pour un chercheur en
philosophie poétique version de twitter
marche clairement dialogues assez
pragmatique vous dirai pas qu'il fait de
la poésie mais il faut qu'il argumente
travail sur ce sujet que la version la
poésie on élit domicile autres est
devenue une version d'essai transformé
en lauzes official ou l'irlande
fabien sur twitter vient remplacer les
phrases lyriques par des jeux seront pas
qu'il y ait une cahill forcément c'est
ok des fois je suis assez durs contre le
mot ce tropisme une la plupart du temps
il s'est plaint de façon assez polis
mais ces arguments qui est en tout cas
très à côté de la plaque et qui ne
réfute pas le point que petit post robe
essaie de nous faire et du coup je file
à côté des gens qui argumentait assemat
elle m'a dit ah c'est de mauvaise foi de
ce côté les partisans de la ligne futur
schéma de façon très posé très très
calme très argumentée et c'est seulement
parce que j'avais l'impression que des
gens ont fait le même observation pour
le au sujet du végétalisme et il y avait
le youtube heures link zelda qui a fait
une vidéo sur le volontariat nice mais
s'était pris une grosse chute sept ans
après du coup j'avais jamais qu'il avait
fait un blog après pour des brises de
cette affaire là parce qu'en gros il
était en train de devenir végétarien
à l'époque il expliqué qu'il était en
train de devenir un véritable parce que
exactement voilà une raison c'est à dire
au début
gd vegas et c'est des connards une
franchise du coude et quelqu'un défoncé
végétarien sur sur facebook twitter
vas-y mon champion mais en fait leurs
arguments sont mauvais et offrir aux
flèches plus d'accord les arguments des
végétariens que les antilles du gîte à
rien sympa la difficulté de séparer les
arguments déjà du rayonnement motivé que
l'on a tous auquel est difficile de
lutter en plus aussi des ces phrases un
peu qu'ils ont l'air convaincante
foisonnant un peu cassantes qui menèrent
convaincante
vu de loin concept convaincu a recruté à
licques et ses co op den bos en fait
c'est une étape intermédiaire ou gt tour
globalement pas d'accord mais où ou déjà
de relever j'ai déjà vu la différence
avec le passé c'est que j'avais admis
comment il avait une démarche honnête qu
il essaie de faire un raisonnement de
dérouler heureusement étape par étape
est ce que ne faisait pas les ses
détracteurs de gauche ils étaient au
moins pu peu réfléchi que même si même
si au final il avait peut-être eu un
raisonnement profondément miss guided au
moins il sa démarche
à ce stade je considérais que ça démarre
fort semblait connaître
mais même si je soutenais encore d'avoir
de faire pas mal de vraiment motivé
kryptonite cox tient à revenir ce n'est
peut-être pas le raisonnement que
faisait bostrom mais au final des gens
comme comme comédie on fait un peu le
tour entre ces réflexions là et le
bashing dang
qui fonctionne à fond aujourd'hui c'est
à dire que ces considérations de nexity
tu peux les avoir avec le machine
learning qui en pleine expansion
aujourd'hui il ya là des coups ça fait
vraiment ce que j'avais lu une fois il
ya longtemps pour si je l'avais écouté
entièrement en livre audio
quelle version libre et où j'ai écouté
la version robe d'été du coup les tpg
vraiment différente il parlait un peu
plus de machines dans la deuxième et
enfin du coup il dit écoute je vous et
nous livrent toujours aussi chiant que
vous même est effectivement plus peut
enfin je comprenais mieux là la même
démarche la motivation qui fait qu'il
avait derrière ce que moi la première
fois que j'ai écouté bustros
j'ai trouvé cela plus où j'ai pas trouvé
ça débile je trouve que ça voilà une
réflexion parmi tant d'autres mais pas
pas du tout et j'ai pas vraiment été
convaincu par j'ai fait qu écouter sous
une voiture
si j'ai lu quelques bouts mais j'ai
essentiellement écouter ce bouquin je me
suis entraîné que la deuxième fois que
j'ai écouté ce bouquin ce que je me suis
dit ouais quand même quelque chose j'ai
l'impression d'avoir loupé j'ai eu une
approche très différente elle comprend
sont très différentes des idées de
boston et qui m'a fait beaucoup plus
réfléchir je pense que ça m'inquiète pas
facilement de ses idées laurent pichon
alors faites-vous pour la plupart des
gens je penserais plutôt de lire le jeu
dans un premier temps le bouquin de max
tegmark la r30 qui est beaucoup plus
accessible
un exemple sympa au début ça va surtout
il faut que je l'avais lu à la fin dans
les chapitres
je n'ai forme à peu les chercheurs en y
aller dans sa peinture est surveillé
avec détecteur de mensonges faut faire
attention à ce qu'ils créent pas de vie
est magnifique mais il est fou ce type
voulant faire du quad il suggère pas
vraiment saluer surinterpréter mai mais
il ya aussi un outil qui me dérangeait
beaucoup c'est que la première lecture
c'est d'un côté je trouvais ça un peu
débile et d'un autre côté ça me faisait
peur parce que les parties de moi qui
trouvais pas ça totalement délivrance
pas totalement
ça pourrait arriver je le disais c'est
en fait différente prophétie
auto-réalisatrice qu'en gros il va créer
le problème dont il va nous protéger
il y avait pas mal ça c'est que tant
qu'on nous considère pas que c'est lié à
deux niveaux humain et qui est en danger
on peut vraiment avoir besoin qui crée
un danger surtout j'avais l'impression
que la manière dont parlait de créer
était une manière très spécifique
n'essayez pas d'avoir les chercheurs en
ya maintenant je joue pas mal changé
d'avis parce que effectivement il est
dans la machine learning pas une espèce
de fonction d'objectifs implicite aussi
de l'autre aspect qui me faisait peur
c'est que je me dis dès la 2 cohérente
extrapolé traditionnels de l'art
présenté différemment de la manière dont
je me la représente aujourd'hui c'est à
dire que pour moi ça on pouvait que
finir comme dans ta vidéo catastrophe de
l'ia ou ce qui pourrait expliquer cette
idée n'a pas vu la vidéo
je suis assez sûr pas la même chose mais
par beau temps il prends souvent
l'exemple de la machine équipée des
trombones tu peux dire c'est facile tu
diffères et robben et puis ça va faire
des trombones et puis voit sa vie n'est
pas si c'est grand je pense que c'est
pas un très bon exemple pédagogique
parce que mon première réaction c'est de
se dire mais pour qu'on parle d'eux
trouvé qu'on justifie aussi de débit
d'avenir c'est pour ça qu'il faut mieux
jouer au jeu des trombones et ensuite
d'abord forgé des cro-magnons ensuite
lire au score mais on est plus
sensibilisé on se met dans la peau des
actifs et des grands moteurs dire alors
en effet s'il veut vraiment être
efficacement pour seul but à la con
parce que ça sert un but de jeux vidéo
ben je vais faire mes trucs horribles
optimisée et mauritanienne j'en suis
tous les humains à 700 à ces ingrédients
parce que du coup dans un jeu vidéo on
se donne l'objectif qui nous est donnée
par le jeu vidéo qu'on se pose la
question c'est si j'avais ce mois cet
objectif moi je suis ni au niveau du bac
qu'est ce que je ferais ça change
vraiment optimisé optimisée de la même
manière qu'on optimise la production de
viande avec ça fait un peu peur mais
d'autres données qui opposera demain
exemple par exemple ok là on pourrait
dire aucun logis à fait juste dit
trombone comme ça va pas détruire
l'humanité oui mais du coup il va passer
l'éternité à s'assurer qu'elle a bien
fait exactement dit robben donc
convertir l'humanité en ressources
informatiques pour s'assurer que l'adf
alcoolique robben encore que c'était cet
exemple je pense que l'exemple et reuben
peut être résolu entre guillemets en
disant faites dit trombone avec une
probabilité 99%
là je pense qu'elle pourrait le faire
sans détruire après tu vas voir de
l'incertitude sur son incertitude du
genre je sais ce que je pensais avant
mais depuis que tu parles de bizet
niçois jeu il faut pas est-ce que ça des
choses te paraître incertitudes
d'incertitude est ce qu'il faut pas au
final toujours multiplie toutes les
probabilités et à la fin toujours de
donner une probabilité tu as donné une
probabilité mais hautes et une
incertitude sur cette priorité
ces sites et acquiert à notre
information tu peux améliorer
l'expérience et a fini sa qualité parce
que je n'avais pas les seuils à il ya
deux ans et demi comment expliquer que
c'était un peu ça n'a pas de sens que ce
cultive mélanger les rôles sont inversés
car il parlait d'un certifiés sur
l'incertitude c'est me semble cependant
indispensable c'est son côté l'enfant de
veille
ces théories soit ceux des théories qui
ont des positions avait listé sur les
probabilités ça ne la probabilité que la
probabilité soit différente si je
j'avais toute sa formation que j'ai pas
encore donc il ya une incertitude sur la
certitude et est ce que ça veut dire
en pratique si tu veux prendre une
décision c'est un cadre de prise de
décision parce qu'ils intéressent c'est
l'état de ta connaissance actuelle et à
ce moment là tu prends la moyenne de
comptabilité mais ces deux cités dans un
cadre où tu peux aller à accéder à
davantage de données pour affinités tt
décisions futures
là par contre avoir une incertitude sur
un certain façon parce que ça me permet
de savoir si les données que tu vas
délecter de bonnes chances d'améliorer
il faut avoir un préjugé sur
l'importance de l'impact que pourraient
avoir les données de voter sur deux et
expliquera ce mouton dans la vidéo 46 où
j'étais à voir mais en gros dos du coup
l'élève solution finale il veut pas pas
forcément finale mais la dernière qui
propose dans son livre de la plus
aboutie c'est ce qu'on appelle cohérente
et rappelez vous des chutes et envoie
une expression un peu pédante pour dire
ben essayer de la fonction objectif de
ligue 1 ça devrait être la fonction
objectif de noray si on était plus
intelligent
quoi que je puisse vouloir dire déjà
deux dans un premier temps on pourrait
se dire on va oublier extrapolé cnid
c'est à dire simplement la fonction
objectifs qu'on aurait noué humain sans
doute pas mal de problèmes mais pas des
problèmes du genre convertir l'univers
rock promod au moins si l'on peut se
dire quitte à faire ça autant essayer de
prédire ce que voudrait de meilleure
version de nous mêmes même si là ça pose
beaucoup de problèmes philosophiques sur
qu'est-ce qu'une meilleure version de
nous-mêmes jusqu où est-ce qu'on veut
pousser ça mais à l'époque je faisais
avant les faits que ce serait juste une
version un peu plus complexe de
l'utilité respect bête et méchant et au
final ça finirait à peu près par les
quadras vécu de stimulation
bonheur éternel mais non je pense à
beaucoup
enfin tout dépend de la manière de ce
qu'on entend par meilleure version de
nous-mêmes laquelle le coeur du problème
mais on peut en tout cas sûrement
imaginer certaines versions ou parents
n'auraient pas des catastrophes de
trombone et où d'autre part même si ce
serait pas parfait on devrait a priori
des résultats potentiellement très
positif donc ça c'est ce que dans les
grandes modifications cours des trois
dernières années on va dire réflexion
parce qu'elle était un peu plus frais
sont les quelques derniers mois ci mais
détrompez à van damme ou en tout cas
serrée sens et c'est l'histoire de la
virulence justement l époque où et quand
j'avais 14 ans et que les élites que je
trouvais ça trop destroy
ce sera un peu la parole j'ai découvert
internet et sur un patch de
l'inscription sur un forum avec un
espèce d'avatar d'aristocrates du xviiie
siècle
je cassais les gens avec des phrases
super sophistiqué façon voltaire et
j'étais très fier de moi et en plus les
gens ne mettez y avait pas encore de
laïques et l'époque c'étaient des lieux
forum mais j'avais des retours positifs
à défoncer comme commentateur télé marc
olivier fogiel l'accaparement et bien
détruire ces intervenants de manière
très très méchante et du coup c'est un
état d'esprit dans lequel j'ai été
pendant de très nombreuses années que je
me disais de ne pas il faut casser parce
que c'est cool c'est stylé comme brice
de nice
je n'ai pas d'autre part offert dans des
basses le fonds apporte
si si les gens sont trop faibles pour
comment ça pleurniche et parce qu'on les
a cassés bas les fêtes doivent périr ça
encore que je rende eu un peu mal non
c'est récemment réalisé que la forme a
une importance finale mais maintenant je
veux dire sur la question
j'ai fait mon dictateur bisounours assez
ce sera assurément à la liberté
d'expression autant sur le fond des
idées c'est à dire la diversité des
billets qu'on peut exprimer
nash je trouve que c'est effectivement
que c'est important qu'ils grande
liberté d'expression' idées nos têtes
dans cette dynamique en tout cas qui
grande liberté pour parce que s'il se
restreindre est-ce que de faire des
bêtises commandé par contre juste moins
en moins de scrupules à promouvoir la le
fascisme sur la forme c'est à dire la
tolérance de la douleur les acteurs
nommés autant on peut exprimer une
grande variété d'idées autant ce qu'ils
expriment de manière virulente ou
cassant plus respectueuse sarcastique
si par exemple la lettre depuis peu là
il ya eu un discours de transhumanistes
qui a été lancé je suis un chien des
amis même si je suis pas la mine
principale
jusque là les gens étaient encore un peu
gentil mais a priori la politique c'est
servir de décharge un divertissement et
je pense que je suis censé si on
appliquait si ça c'est autant la norme
que par exemple ne pas dire de trucs
raciste dans une conversation mais le
bas sur ça fera chier les gens au début
mais je pense que globalement ce serait
une grosse amélioration de nos
discussions parce que sachant que toute
idée même d idées extrêmes nous n'hésite
pas à s'exprimer de façon
bon virulente sa chance à qu aucune
excuse pour le faire de façon virulente
tu fais ce que tu avais répondu une fois
le langage bisounours et urine complet
peut-être me tromper mais a priori je ne
vois aucune idée aussi folle bizarre ce
ne peut être que qu'on puisse pas
exprimé de façon posée pour toise
logique
ça me fait penser à un podcast de julian
f où elle parlait de transhumanisme et
avec massimo pupillo jean quelle époque
l'épisode et je pense qu'elle pense et
notamment pas mal à boston dont elle
parlait de transhumanisme est due à
gafsa faisait vraiment la réflexion que
ouais les idées qui sont défendues sons
sont très bizarres sont très inhabituels
surtout et vont à l'encontre de pas mal
de trucs renseigner en philosophie des
pizzas mais à ce que je gagne c'est que
voilà les arguments sont proposés par
niveaux sont pas parlés transhumanisme
remontrances moniste et ils sont posés
sont assez on est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord nous au moins ils sont souvent
bien expliqué et puis surtout ils sont
expliqué avec beaucoup de bons réflexes
de débats pense que j'appelle des bons
avec ce débat je pense qu'ils utilisent
d'autres terminologies mets typiquement
la bienveillance l'absence de virulence
la modestie épistémique donation par
opposition à lui demander d attaquer du
transhumanisme qui qui était beaucoup
moins dans avec ses bons marqueurs de
débats jorge j'ai l'impression qu'il me
serait ce que dans le domaine des des
gens qui sont contre le troisième à nice
mme déjean il peut y avoir des bons
arguments qu'on colle transhumanistes
mais parmi tous les mauvais argument je
pense que si on mettait comme condition
non négociable que tu dois exprimer de
manière calme posé payante
beaucoup de discours s'était fait de les
reformuler comme ça discours parce que
c'est ce que c'est que de la virulence
mais il la poésie là il faut sont donc
peut-être les excédents de vidéos sur ça
mais la virulence qui voudra de
pollution on est face à moi dans une
discussion
si on est quatre kim a un qui est
violent bas gâche pas mal et souvent ça
les pousse à être là mais j'avais fait
un petit peu de french bashing mais j'ai
l'impression que sa violence ses traits
à valoriser en france parce que je pars
d'où ça vient je pense que c'est
peut-être la culture voltairienne quoi
ça s'appelle voltaire c'est un
personnage qu'on valorise énormément à
l'école que ce type qui écrit des
pamphlets avec sa plume votre image
décalée avec sa plume et faire un
crochet terre détruit des routes vers
les lumières sont moins d'être puni
malgré ces clashs entre je fonce tout le
monde a entendu parler à l'école de
l'idée l'ironie voltairienne au four et
revendique bon sarcastique très dans
l'exagération homebrew y avait 10 des
outils d irène rempli par rapport au roi
à l'époque ce qui pouvait avoir un
intérêt politique
oui pourquoi pas mais aujourd'hui
comment est pour l'instant en tout cas
pour mettre les années à venir après on
ne sait pas on est encore dans une
société
ce qu'on appelle une faune societies
c'est à dire une société où on peut
parler de ce qu'on veut sans être trop
inquiété ça je me dis ça par rapport à
des pays vers la corée du nord ce qui
est des gens qui vont dire a avoué on
peut pas dire des trucs raciste on n'est
pas libre a réussi sa relativement à
d'autres pays où il ya clairement pas le
même niveau de liberté d'expression mais
globalement on n'est pas des peuples
mais tant qu'on est dans une open
society et il n'y pas pas dans un
contexte où il ya il
archi t'empêche de te dire des trucs
force content on a intérêt à être pas
virulent parce qu'elle allait de la
virulence de reprendre des termes un peu
un week-end démocrate sa menace la
démocratie face à face à sa menace
ce climat de open society où on peut
librement exprimer des idées ça pousse
un extrémisme j'ai également beaucoup à
noter aux censeurs ces gens vous peur de
la censure
il faut bien ce mouvement que dans un
environnement très virulent c'est une
forme de censure
c'est une forme de censure et il ya
beaucoup de youtuber scientifique qui
n'osent pas aborder certains sujets
scientifiques avec un consensus
scientifique parce que cette dame il
doit pas qu'il s'est fait appeler des
teams des choses at il avait posté un
but un peu triste soit mais j'ai un truc
intéressant à dire mais du coup j'ai pas
le dire parce que très peu dur à avoir
de sujet des défis là dans le temps
d'étude scientifique
le coût serait trop puis pareil a parlé
de dégâts nisme y en a un qui a osé s'y
filer c'est pas facile
les sujets qui divisent énormément pas
facile à aborder et du coup ça a créé de
l'autocensure et ne peux pas en parler
calmement parler des arguments pour au
comptant des quizz de dire non ce regard
des artistes dans l'association
transhumanistes me voyez il va être
énervé si tu écoutes les podcasts et
empile c'est quittera très calmes et
gentils sur tous les sujets sauf le
véganisme et du coup dès que ça paraît
devait gagner mais il était non
seulement il pète un câble il fait
condamnation on n'en parle comme s'il
parlait de benghazi qu'ils sont mineurs
comme s'il était fou de rage après mes
deux et problème c'est qu'il s'estime
légitime à parler comme ça des mini
c'est quand on lui dit quatre fois et 6
et de calme et c'est pas c'est pas parce
que la cause était opinion tata droit
d'être contre gagné c'est parce que la
forme n'est pas acceptable quoi on
essaie de censure et c'est ma fille
avait gagné pour aller voir ce que des
camps des gens sont indignés sur un
sujet même quand ils le sont à raison il
s'estime légitime à être virulent mais
c'est que du coup comme tout le monde à
des sujets d'indignation bas tout le
monde s'estime être virulent sur
certains sujets en ce sens quoique la
photo fait au moins un effort ouais
ouais légitimité européenne sur plein de
sujets notamment dans les sujets où les
gens se considèrent victimes et quelque
chose justifie beaucoup plus à être
virulent et du coup on voit
malheureusement beaucoup de virulence
autour de ces sujets où certaines
personnes se considère victime et à
raison sans doute puisque sans doute
raison mais cette légitimité justifie
une tente de virulence qui ne me semble
pas contribué à ceux qui cherchent un
moment bah j'ai vu une discussion de
twitter est un sujet sensible et
compliqué parce que on n'a pas envie de
temps la position du méchant patriarcale
privilégiés qui va dire à des gens vous
devriez pas vous énervez vous êtes bien
souvent aux hormones qui ce genre de
remarque
on n'a pas envie d'être cette personne
là mais en même temps bah oui ok mais du
coup les personnes qui s'indignent sur
ce sujet là et si du coup ses clones de
façon durable certaine manière je ne
peux rien pour elle que je juste pas
discuter avec elle parce que on peut pas
discuter au delà d'un certain niveau de
violence du coup je
je me contente discuter avec des gens
qui acceptent de discuter de façon plus
violente et j'ai pas de solution je
pense que essayer d'amener s'élevant à
réfléchir et à chaud c'est ça c'est très
difficile que mais a essayé de les
propager l'idée selon laquelle ce n'est
pas parce qu'on est un être vivant c'est
justifié que la virulence et la
stratégie souhaitable pour défendre les
idées que je défends est autant ça c'est
une raison possible et autant dire à
jobs plein d'autres raisons que pouvoir
l'enlever joueurs par exemple le fait
que ce soit valorisé socialement ça on
devrait cependant s'en débarrasse c'est
dire si on enlevait la partie
c'est cool d'être violent parce que ça
montre était engagée à des convictions
je n'aurais pas trop de pathos scrupule
à critiquer c'est inné là et si mauvaise
et des ménages pensent que tout le monde
sera globalement moins virulent quel que
soit le niveau de violence ça que c'est
certain mais le côté cool de la violence
c'est toujours un petit peu si tu as un
petit peu frustré d'avoir cessé ses
tweets qui sont très violent de façon
légitime parce que la personne est une
victime et qui ont dix mille retweet
parce que les gens sont mises s'écouler
valoriser l'image infléchir un petit peu
parce que c'est plus les terres de
réfléchir davantage aux effets twitter
sera encouragé les pins et chênes vu que
c'est la classe et dignité donc il faut
que vrai mais c'est aussi les ritualité
les laïcs et des gens qui encouragent du
point de vue de la personne qui fait
l'appel mais du point de vue des gens
qui encouragent
c'est une personne de mon camp elle a
démoli le coup quand en face dans son
tweet avec partage
je vais changer d'avis aussi avait vite
fait là c'est pareil denis bostrom tout
à l'heure et running bostrom c'est
quelqu'un qui il était plus jeune était
apparemment très investi dans dans lé
mouvement transhumaniste il en a
notamment créé l'association en transit
maritime mondial avec va le philosophe
et de la vie de corse on lui dit aristo
radical on va reparler plus où il avait
écrit la fable de drames anti angle est
en fait il s'est un peu éloigné du
mouvement transhumaniste donc maintenant
il se consacre plutôt aux problèmes de
sécurité désiré compagnie ea il parlait
de sa notion d' entendre dans une vidéo
youtube il a raison qui donnait c'est
que là il paraît sur nous des
transhumanistes plutôt californien
silicon valley c'est qu'il trouvait que
dans le mouvement transhumaniste elle
est trop de gens qui se sentaient
obligés d'être des pommes sur le site du
post rock de pop punk google donc cher
leader du progrès technologique c'est à
dire dès qu'il ya un nouveau truc
inventé il faut être dire que c'est
génial parce que l'on estime panda
technologique et même s'il ya des
risques il faut les mettre sous le tapis
parce qu'il faut encourager notre équipe
du coup c'est en tout cas c'est pas du
tout la vision du transhumanisme que je
défends pas il faut aussi si c'est un
p2c transhumanistes ça veut dire ni les
risques je suis pas tant des risques
mais non je me sens bien on peut tout à
fait être globalement favorable au moins
viser de ces technologies a buté à un
peu lointain vers on pourrait traduire
un transit manistes extrêmement prudent
et précautionneux et très attentif aux
risques tout en considérant que par
exemple ce serait bonne chose dans
l'idéal de vivre 50 ans et plus en bonne
santé grâce à certaines parfaite
transition pour parler un peu plus d
transmises les questions abordées les
grands domaines
quel dommage d'après moi il y en a
beaucoup mais jeanjean suit souvent
trois principaux le premier c'est bien
sur l'allongement radicale de la durée
de vie en bonne santé de façon un peu
compliquée parce que si je précise pas
les gens disent ah vous voulez qu'on
reste que en 200 ans de plus sur le but
c'est de ralentir le vieillissement
voire de stopper ou même de l'inversé
à l'inversé des semences à ceux qui sont
complètement fou mais ça va et plus je
me dis que c'est pas si c'est à dire que
sa grande rivale faire de façon très
partielle sur des micro organismes
mais pas seulement le ralentir mais
carrément l'inversé faire ce qu'on
appelle de la régie vi nations
ok sur des plaintes sur des trucs un peu
plus un taux d'abonnées déjà sur par
exemple sur des ce fait on peut faire ce
qu'on appelle de nettoyer leurs cellules
sénescentes bon ça n'a pas les rendre
immortel mais c'est pas mal a demandé
l'autre dumas de vie après le passage
souris humain est beaucoup plus complexe
qu'on pourrait l'imaginer parce qu'on
pourrait dire ces mammifères c'est un
peu pareil mais apparemment je pense
qu'on aura la souris morte elle
travaille en temps avant l'allumage mais
aussi aimerait faire sur des sources et
puis on va on fait encore plus de
traction des bactéries ou sur des vers
de terre
bref ça c'est un gros aspect puisque le
plus consensuel parmi les transits quand
vous je connais pratiquement aucune
personne qui se dit transhumanistes et
qui n'est pas prêt je mens radical de m6
effectivement j'en profite pour regarder
les vidéos de monsieur fille de son
sujet est pris aussi nantes a lieu
récemment et de guilhem et becker ce qui
est ce qui a renoncé à chercheurs cnrs
qui est lancé ces initiatives privées
sur le sujet en le lui il travaille
plutôt est ce qu'on appelle j'en parle
dans la terre de ce qu'on appelle des
organes sur plus que ça consiste à faire
des mini modèles d'humains pour simuler
des opérations des interactions entre
organes si on ne va pas vous constituer
un humain mais on peut simuler des
cancers on peut aussi l'aider à baisser
une infection de rein avec de l'alcool
vous ça permet de faire des
expérimentations sur des humains sans
faire des expérimentations sur des
humains ou jamais sur des animaux et je
pense que c'est une piste très
intéressante parce que ça permet en gros
un des gros problèmes dans la façon dont
j'ai quitté c'est qu'on peut pas faire
de tests sur des humains
déjà parce que c'est illégal après on
pourrait parler aussi parce que même si
c'était légal
on est pas mal de problèmes éthiques aux
côtés des humains ce qu'on appelle des
humains sur plus là c'est bon on peut y
aller en pleurant balancer tous les
produits toxiques
mais si ça c'est difficile de faire
beaucoup d'expérience
seul aspect auquel on pense en priorité
que les mêmes sur des personnes qui
parlent des transhumanistes qui
considère que le transhumanisme c'est
juste ça coince et juste à jane holl
lute est sauté la question quelle caisse
commune transhumanistes mme tu veux tuer
définir sa hausse assez rapide parce que
de la même manière après il ya un
milliard de définition que je vois
circuler mais je pense que les
définitions les plus simples sont d'une
certaine manière les plus légitimes
par exemple un peu quand tu as fait
tasser sur la démocratie battu défini
juste la démocratie comme c'est le
peuple qui décide la gamme moyenne
décision à déterminer qui va être le
leader des gens mettent pas d'accord on
dit wen la démocratie c'est des fois on
des minorités c'est défendre des valeurs
bourbon faudrait appeler ça la
démocratie définition démocratie
finition devait a priori la définition
par défaut ça devrait être la plus
simple et évidente
du coup dans cette optique là bas 3e à
nice simplement l'étymologie modifier le
mouse et être favorable à certains trucs
technologie qui pourrait amener à
modifier le moins dans une certaine
direction pas forcément tous à la fois
il ya tous mes mais ce que c'est ça
c'est sa définition mais ce que je sais
pas si c'est une décision que tous les
transhumanistes adot ce que tu dirais
que prendre des médicaments et du
transhumanisme genre après il ya toute
une zone grise passe car oui en effet
quand ils transhumanistes c'est plutôt
pour pareille des trucs qui ne sont pas
considérés comme résidant aujourd'hui
d'à côté on peut dire que les vaccins
c'est une forme de transhumanistes que
tu modifies définitivement son organisme
pour le rendre résistant une maladie
comme ça ça a l'air assez
transhumanistes
mais comme c'est un truc largement
acceptée pourtant c'était pas mal de
gens vont dire que c'est on va pas en
parler comme les transhumanistes même si
on peut ça relève d'une certaine manière
de la de la même démarche
bah c'est juste que les ide m ou montrer
qui on est et de barrières un truc est
pas je pense qu'il est plus un spectre
quoi on est plus ou moins il y aussi
plus facile c'est comme ça
après je vous ai plein de gens qui parce
que l'association transhumanistes on
reçoit plein de demandes d'interviews
avec des questions de journalistes ou
d'étudiants et compagnie sur la question
qui revient souvent c'est quelqu'un
comment définissez vous le
transhumanisme et enfin les gens se sont
vraiment ils éliront un fétichisme et
les définitions que j'aurais à ces
définitions de tan dun et puis il ya
plusieurs définitions possibles
j'avais en effet souhaité cette question
il faut bon c'est ça aura été utile pour
aborder la question du transhumanisme
quand avait déjà fait une transition je
suis dit bon bah on va parler
directement de des sujets intéressants c
en est mais moi ce que je veux ajouter
c'est que beaucoup de gens je sais pas
pourquoi parce que ça sente assez
spécifique ou trois une manif c'est
considère que transhumanistes c'est une
liste de cases à cocher c'est à dire
ouais ouais on jouera du réduite vont
être pour la cryogénisation de noël pour
si l'organisation d'environ peut très
bien mais alice sûr mais juste favorable
à un feu de ces aspects c'est du
transhumanisme ma définition ultra
simple donc l'autre est radicalement
opposé à tous les aspects et c'est
vraiment ces regards est très large et
que nous dit les vaccins c'est une sorte
de transe humanisme tous qui n'a pas à
paris à dire que c'est aussi l'histoire
de l'art et la différence réparation
augmentation c'est vrai que parce que
vous n'avez akçam même si c'est
discutable pour les vaccins tu peux
encore te dire que tu essayes juste de
revenir à un état de santé qui est entre
guillemets normal même si normalement
sur les axes saisir que c'est une
augmentation avec une allusion quand
même le principe du vaccin ça semble
relativement relativement proche des
médicaments du coup ça
les gens classés dans la même catégorie
alors que je peux vivre 200 ans d'un
couple plus bizarre si on veut vraiment
ramener les tric trac le plus bas le
plaisir si tu manges d'eilat une
modification à kenny donc pas contre
manger a décidé encore on utilise le mot
transhumanistes si on peut parler des
tricots s'ils vont être au delà du
spectre ceux qui vont être assez
perturbant pour qu'on ait besoin de
tavaux qu'est le mou transhumanistes
parce que sinon ce serait vu des trucs
que par l'ajout de vaccins mais je vois
déjà les vaccins pour certaines
personnes c'est déjà de quartier oui
mais après il ya des gens qui disent que
cette argumentation les bacs censitaire
du transhumanisme trouve que c'est que
c'est fallacieux parce que c'est comme
ça que c'était les vaccins tu dois
accepter tout le reste c'est passer
l'idée que c'est là je veux dire peu
importe où tu mets la limite où c'était
limité flou c'est travailler c'est
transhumer lycée plus auprès de la
direction d'aller vers ça qu'il ya un
peu à côté transgressif serait satisfait
de rejoindre modifier radicalement leur
adn
il ya un côté progressif ça c'est de
prétendre le contraire ou je ne sais pas
ce matin troisième rome ce sera quand
sera plus inutile mais ça serait du
transhumanisme ces augmentations
cognitive interface après ça peut être
est ce que le problème sur certains de
ces sur scène de ces questions c'est
poche
enfin c'est aussi une question de
perception pas dû donc non pas que de la
perception du risque que ça je pense
qu'une perception du risque qui très
grande par rapport à des modifications
génétiques
oui les gens ont tendance à penser que
voit un ogm c'est dongeois typiquement
ben oui ou non parce que dans le pays
mais le sondage ne me suffit sur
imagined par espèce de vaccins qui
permet de vivre 50 et en plus le
quasiment gratuit aucun problème est
compatible même plein de gens qui sont
contre car plus une époque
donc bon pour en venir à bout et aux
aspects du troisième indice doit on
avait parlé de la mobilité
le deuxième aspect qui me semble le plus
important ensuite c'est tout ce qui est
augmentée par aurelio il ya aussi le
fait que le terme l'augmentation est un
peu connoté un sens où il ya une espèce
de la hiérarchie morale la limite je
veux juste te dire modifications
augmentation ou modification cognitive a
priori on préfère me taire plus
intelligent que le plus stupide
améliorer nos capacités cognitives ou
être capable d'être plus créatif où les
plus heureux comme on n'en avait pas mal
parlé au début
ouais même pourquoi pas de sirop
considère que ressentir ça devient des
émotions par exemple par rapport à une
oeuvre d'art c'est positive pour
imaginer se rende capable de 30 artistes
hic encore plus avancé c'est un peu ce
que font les gens qui prennent du lsd
mais tu es genre d'épreuves comme par
exemple avoir un accès à tous les
chipayas sur son téléphone
ça permet quand même de l'argent corse
un truc qui me choque les gens parce que
ces appareils fonctionnent comme une
forme de prothèses mais comme je fais
pas intégrés ou encore les gens on se
dit sans doute à tort que c'est pas
vraiment une partie de mon corps que en
pratique pour pas mal de gens aussi
mais c'est aussi pas mal de
modifications par exemple moi je sais
que j'ai une addiction à twitter que le
fait d'avoir monté fin de constance sur
moi modifie le fonctionnement du cerveau
typiquement pour moi le son à fond c'est
un continuum entre ils ont internet fixe
et les puissants serbe que quelqu'un il
ya un continuum que transhumanistes que
c'est difficile de dire où ça commence
personnellement moi je m'en fiche un peu
là l'important c'est ce qui est
souhaitable de faire ou pas je pense que
c'est d'une part et à ce jeu c'est
intéressant de voir ça comme un
continuum parce que du coup tu peux voir
là où tu es dans ce continuum et puis
surtout je trouve ça très important
devrait insister à nouveau sur cette
question qui est
qu'est-ce qui est désirable c'est plus
ça qui a été son intéressant parce que
l'ennemi vraie question sachez que
certaines personnes mais oui j'ai pas
mal de gens en sciences humaines y
travaillent sur le projet humaniste je
trouve que c'est une bonne chose que les
sciences humaines s'intéresse
transhumanisme france je m'étais dit
mais ces dix ans côté et crabes les
pages et des pages sur la question
qu'est ce que le transit misbah
transhumanistes c'est juste un beau et
ça la définition donnée la limite ce
qu'est ce qui est intéressant c'est
quelle définition les gens qui se
considèrent comme transhumanistes dans
l'outrance d'humanisme en moyenne là ce
sera une question un peu plus objective
cette question serait intéressante parce
que ça sous-entend que ces personnes
seront transmises ça reviendra à poser
la question qu'est ce que selon deux
personnes trouvent désir vient à la
question qu'est-ce que ça peut bien
meilleures encore plus ce qu'ils vont
passer des heures à parler de la nuance
entre france d'humanisme et post
humanisme
perso j'en revenais en question de
l'augmentation cognitive l'alimentation
cognitive en france plus on reste
biologique sur ça sera encore assez
lointain
et brad théorique mais par exemple si on
imaginer avoir davantage de connexions
neuronales ou une plus grande plasticité
the official théorique parce que si
c'est demain matin on a les ont plutôt
fait bouger le curseur de plasticité
je pense que ça améliorera peut-être
certaines choses mais ça causerait avait
plein de problèmes parce que le cerveau
est un équilibre fragile mais pas d'un
autre côté il ya aucune lois de la
physique ne dit que vous ne pourra pas
faire des cerveaux plus complexe très
différent d'attac d'émotion beaucoup
plus intense et que je devrais dès que
je parle d'expérience de vie
intéressante et exaltante et savent ce
que c'est un peu ça le but que je vois
dans le transhumanisme et en particulier
dans cet aspect là qui est le mot nation
cognitive est aussi ce qui s'appelle
d'augmentation maurane être intéressant
pour les utilisatrices
parce que braquer nous sommes un peu des
singes évolué qui gardent ont beaucoup
de saint gengoux mais choisi des gens
c'est que le film 2001 l'odyssée de
l'espace ou au début du jeu vient il ya
des singes qui joue avec un os puis à un
moment les 117 a massacré un médecin le
groupe et nous avons pas mal gardé la
dance un genou et au final on pourrait
dire que c'est vraiment une bonne chose
enfin si on aspire à être dans une
société un peu développés civilisé parce
que d'abord c'est un réflexe par exemple
aux réflexes mari jaloux qui va battre à
mort sa femme
c'est vraiment une bonne chose parce que
c'est indispensable ce qu'on dit c'est
important d'être avec un grand h ok
pourquoi pas mais est ce que c'est
important d'être humains et de battre ça
rejoint un peu le prochain p naturaliste
de saisir si c'est naturel c'est bien
cette saison david d'être évident sam
très discutable
alors naturellement la cour faire de
confusion
ça peut ça qu'ils ajoutent enfin que
jean yanne signerait que se tisse wii
qui est et ce qui doit être
c'est ce qu'on appelle la guillotine de
fioul david young philosophes du xviiie
siècle disait qu' on ne peut jamais
déduire un devra être donnée vers m
enfin l'idée c'est que on peut pas
déduire les préférences morale à partir
uniquement de description du monde il
faut rajouter quelque part d'un postulat
moral au mois pour pouvoir ensuite on
déduire de notre canal beaucoup qui s'en
sert pour moi justifier le fait que
globalement les zones 2000 des femmes
dans la plupart des sociétés ben ça a
marché comme ça pendant des millénaires
donc du coup c'est une quasi voire à un
axiome additionnel pour en arriver à
cette conséquence les actions et il
était clairement c'est un axiome qui
sera largement rejetée par les produits
qui est très exactement où je t'ai pas
par la philosophie morale et à l'éthique
on a été pénalisés et cette distinction
pas paris ni chez beaucoup d'efforts sur
le prédateur a carnassiers voilà la
chapelle fait beaucoup mais ça c est
donc là on a parlé de d2 domaine des
transmissions et 33e mais pas
sélectionné trois ravitaillements pas
c'est ce dont j'avais parlé dans
d'autres les troisièmes c'était tout ce
qui est un peu plus ce que si
l'organisation alors qu'on parle de
sébum on pense tu mourras des structures
terminator on a super force des supers
bras pour faire des bonds de 9 m
pourquoi pas mais ça ne sent pas
l'aspect le plus intéressant dans une
société encore une fausse société qui
expire être civilisé mon patient dit
dans votre bac max toujours si je mets
mes paires de skis pour descendants des
pistes des ski c'est une forme de sites
d'organisations à la nature fait
l'argument du vaccin décembre j'ai fait
un an que je faisais pas mal à une
époque mais maintenant je fais moi parce
que ça ça énerve les gens pour les
mauvaises raisons et la pression mais
oui je dirais plutôt oui c'est une pente
glissante dans le transit des rallonges
adressez vous même avoir avoir des
chaussures c'est s'exposer les pieds
quand encore marche c'est une prothèse
de pau sous les pieds si les vêtements
s'il ne remplaceront pas les niveaux
qu'est ce que les transhumanistes on
compte en suisse par simone isation les
sharks encore passé c'est pas comme les
transhumanistes l'accord peu d'intérêt
aux prothèses amovibles
parce que derrière en passant dans la
mesure où on peut faire des prothèses
amovibles je pense qu'il faut lui faire
ça parce que c'est mieux lentement déjà
c'est nous accepter par les gens qui
vont un peu rétro et humanisme mais en
plus c'est là que ce soit morisod si
jamais on en a marre que pour ensuite
baladé dans les rues de lausanne l'a
fait enlever les semaines paires de skis
puis il n'y a pas de problème
d'infection avec des implants et ce
qu'il ya encore un problème aujourd'hui
dans les prothèses les specs ils sont
vraiment le plus intéressant c'est tout
ce qui est contrôlée communication pour
répondre par avance et ça se disent
peut-être c'est bon il a pété un plomb
qui se fait déjà largement aujourd'hui
maintenant que j'avais une expérience
parmi d'autres il y en a plein à
l'université de stanford il y avait une
personne tétraplégique a complètement
paralysé kouao fonctionnel métier
complètement paralysé du coup on y
mettait un casque avec des électrodes je
sais pas quel point est invasive mais
c'est suffisant pour que cette personne
puisse contrôler un curseur sur un écran
du coup elle va un peu il peut taper du
texte avec et faire des phrases cette
personne est assez formidable
sauf que cette technologie et il n'ya
pas besoin d'être handicapé pour
mépriser qu'on peut très bien par
exemple il y avait un artiste un peu
transhumanistes il y avait appris à
piloter un troisième bras robotiques
s'adresse attachées dans le dos par la
pensée de la même manière en joue et ça
c'est encore un petit peu rudimentaire
fait pas des mouvements trajet tu vois
pas jouer au foot mais je pense ça va
largement s'améliorer
je pense qu'à terme à une application
intéressante c'est pas tant les
prothèses les bras ou psychobenny parce
que çà çà çà çà çà c'était si nous
prenons un peu personnel je veux faire
une parenthèse ça ça m'énerve un peu que
quand on parle de transhumanistes dans
l'éventuelle suite voir des bras
robotiques parce que je comprends
pourquoi les journalistes pour ça parce
qu'ils veulent des visuels pour
illustrer ya eu fort et clair on dit
qu'on a l'impression que les
transhumanistes c'est des gens qui
veulent se couper un bras pour semer par
un bras robotique
on sait pas trop pourquoi parce que
c'est cool quoi elle me dit qu'elles
étaient des gens qui veulent faire ça
dans une démarche qu'on appelle side are
punk il faut qu'ils s'appellent mission
personnelle ça il fait plaisir de se
complaire à brest par le bras robotique
je suis totalement favorable à ce genre
de liberté corporelle mais
personnellement je vois pas trop
l'intérêt surtout si le bras robotique
fait pas grand chose en plus que le bras
rennes et qu'en plus il ya dix ans plus
tôt elle se plaît au final société se
veut avancer ce qu'on fait c'est surtout
de la manipulation d'informations ce qui
me passait plus prothèse informationnel
par exemple si tu peux contrôler les
autres par la pensée et le faire de
manière assez précise de manière aussi
précise que tu contrôles damas bas par
exemple je pense que dans un futur pas
forcément si lointain on tapera plus du
texte ou clavier avec un bout des doigts
mais a simplement tu penses ou un
premier temps tu penses que m elle est
sacrée lettre dont il pourrait même
penser d'actes mans france accueillera
l'épreuve
ouais j'ai un petit peu à ça et je
souhaite enfin moi personnellement j'ai
l'impression que le clavier est pas
tellement le truc limitant à l'écriture
de livres ou de scripts c'est vraiment
juste mes facultés cognitives qui me
ralentit dans un livre
oui je pense mais par exemple si tu
étais subventions sur dans une chatroom
parce que c'est limite quand même c'est
quand même plus lent que par les
alouettes
ce qui inquiète paris à l'oral mais en
même temps ça a ralenti pour de bonnes
raisons
narcisse est écrite essaie d'écrire un
truc de qualité faisant pas mal d'être
ralenti dans la façon d'écrire aurait
clairement c'est cette discussion ne
pourrait pas avoir eu à l'écrit ça
serait vraiment chez moi faire mais je
trouve ça quand même encore assez
intéressant mais ça qui les hisse à ce
débat s'il y aura sans doute des modes
de communication qui pointent techno
plus efficace qu'à l'oral l'us open le
deuxième aspect donc déjà dans un
premier temps je pense que si vous
pouvez on avait une espèce de process
cette diffusion fret non invasives dans
le meilleur des cas simplement un qu'est
ce que tu fous sur la dette et tue plus
contrôlés que probante aux ordinateurs
en cinq dimensions
ça se peut aller beaucoup plus vite dans
de nombreux cas c'est le deuxième aspect
c'est communication par la pensée on l'a
encore fait science fiction mais ça se
fait déjà de façon rudimentaire il ya
des expériences de communication pour la
pensée ou mais récemment franck sanson a
servi il y avait un aspect du jeu assez
simple en collectif et puis les
participants la même équipe comme guest
pas par l'oral mais par la pensée c'est
très casse et du coup on pourra aller
par exemple futur moi quand on n'est pas
forcément sinon à part battu pour être
déjà communiquer par la pensée de comme
tu parles tu pensé ça ça fait un peu
peur parce que tu peux pas autoroutes au
sens fort vraiment des systèmes sécurité
bras parce que déjà aujourd'hui c'est un
gros point pour moi sur mon téléphone
pour les familles notification à
l'édification c'est vraiment un truc dia
sur mon téléphone je bloque beaucoup
dans ma tête mais je vais chanter plutôt
à communiquer par exemple entre deux
personnes ou encore plus m
et après c'est une fois que tu es engagé
une discussion serait que c'est agréable
d'avoir
une bonne incitant vivre en d1
discussions d'avoir une bande passante
importante joue peut-être que notre
bande passante de réflexion s'est adapté
au fait qu'on est imité par la vitesse
de débit à l'oral mais que si on avait
pu cette limite on pourrait commencer à
s'entraîner à penser et communiquer
beaucoup plus vite
qu'est ce ça c'est ouvrir des
possibilités qu'est ce que je vais dans
certains cas cela peut être vraiment
dans notre cas dans un des bouquins des
immeubles un délit fondation il ya un
truc qui sont une espèce de consignes
politiques afin de décideurs qui se
faire en communication directe par la
pensée donc il est de communiquer des
idées de façon ultra rapide
ouais et ultra précises parce que là
encore je parlais un peu de communiquer
par la pensée au final comment
communiquer à l'oral nom pourrait aller
encore plus loin et communiquer
directement dépenser sans passer par pro
formulation en mots et en phrases ou
pour que ça puisse vouloir des renforts
pourrait creuser dans cette direction
niveau entre ces trois domaines donc à
la longévité
l'augmentation des capacités cognitives
et la sib organisation a évolué parce
qu'elles sont tes priorités
et quand tu as évolué moi je suis pas
très bon pour la sépare de priorité du
pas tout me semble intéressant mais
après il ya ce qui veut dire qu'il faut
prendre en compte aussi c'est le fait
que par exemple puisqu'ils augmentation
cognitif par rapport aux deux autres
aspects longévité communication à la
pensée c'est beaucoup plus complexe et
là on est vraiment on sait même pas
comment on pourrait commencer à le faire
que je pense à court terme il est plus
intéressant de parler d'un allongement
des durées de vie ou de la paire face au
cerveau machine mais à vallabrègues il
par rapport à ce que séoul eut des bus
sur nous rendre capables d'expériences
de vie beaucoup plus sophistiqué quand
je dis nous c'est finalement ce serait
un point moi mais à la limite si on
meurt de vieillesse et que c'est long
trois générations c'est quand même bien
sabrosa droit rod on imaginer que dans
trois générations dans 30 génération
successeurs pouvons avoir des
expériences de vie beaucoup plus intense
est intéressante mais aussi de la
spécialité way par un petit intérêt
particulier parce que si tu veux boire
toute la suite et sexy chic si je
raisonne qu'en termes de d'efficacité
des avances ou est-ce que l'énergie doit
dépenser aujourd'hui détenait des
transmissions selon quels critères sont
ont pris des risques et qu'est ce que tu
penses qu'on est né de transe man is me
devrait mettre peut se dépensa peu pour
des raisons marketing
je pense au fond c'est l'aspect qui le
moins choquant pas qu'ils ne soient pas
choquant mais moins chaud qu en général
ces lancements de la durée de vie parce
que c'est même juste pas aller vivre 50
ans et plus en bonne santé
il ya plein de positions juste un mec
c'est encore ça suffit j'ai envie d'en
faire de même pas mal des gens pour
accepter en discutant en réfléchissant
un peu plus à ce sujet quoi çà çà çà çà
çà me première phase i say say say il ya
des gens qui vont pas être content nous
nous pas parce que c'est dangereux et
c'est contre nature des compagnies mais
simplement parce que ils voient pas
terrain de disques longtemps c'est du
coup je me dis qu'un truc qui ferait
faudrait faire en amont du transit m'a
dit c'est qui au fond serait encore plus
important c'est ce même pas du convoi
recueillant des transhumanistes et de
les amener à être dans le même état
d'esprit que moi ou d'autres personnes
qui fait qu' il découle de cet état
d'esprit que je suis troisième and east
par exemple cet état d'esprit ça va être
le fait de valoriser beaucoup de temps
de ligue 2 n'ont pas forcément de façon
optimale parce que je suis assez sur ce
plan là mais moi si on veut dire en plus
je prends c'est positif mais je manque
un truc à faire et on aura encore plus
dans le futur
la cap par rapport à soigner des gens
qui ont des réactions que ça me déprime
peut penser que c'est de se dire vie fut
longtemps que pour quoi faire dire je me
fais chier dimanche après midi mais on
revient oui c'était état d'esprit qu'il
paierait qui rend les gens 3 humanisme
sont plus intéressantes à plus important
à promouvoir que le transhumanisme parce
que là l'émission en effet d'argumenter
pour les transhumanistes avec des gens
qui n'ont pas cet état d'esprit pas ça
ça forcément mal ce que cette ligue et
donc montrer d'abord enfin essayer
d'encourager les gens à trouver de la
joie dans le temps qui passe la belle
reese et ça j'ai vraiment essayé de
faire avec ma vidéo la cour mais je veut
s'assurer que je pense aborder plus sur
youtube c'est se mettre dans un état
d'esprit où des gens ont considéré que
j'ai longtemps serait clairement positif
ouais et je suis juste en face moment
j'ai dit j'ai choqué des transhumanistes
et s'il écoute mais enfin je considère
même pas que si priorité absolue dans le
monde s'est vu ce que les trans monisme
c'est ce qui m'importe c'est plus là ça
dommage qui célébrant ses possibilités
ne serait ce que sur le long terme sont
vraiment assez vertigineuse et
fascinante des risques et compagnie ça
déprimant de voir à quel point les gens
sont ici 6 par rapport à ça va dans le
sens souhaité pour quoi faire
quel intérêt ouais ça peut presque dire
de ne pas être exaltée par ses
perspectives et je me parle pour l'heure
droite dure a dit je dis pas que ça doit
être la priorité numéro un de la
médecine encore que ça pourrait aider
pas mal d'autres aspects liés à messi
mais juste
c'est bizarre qu'on y consacre un budget
aussi dérisoire sachant les monts otish
le biologiste le dire clairement il ya
des tonnes de deux pistes de recherches
possibles dans l'allongement de la durée
dit me semble travail esat de croire que
si on mettait un budget conséquent
ne serait ce que la moitié du budget
consacre à la recherche contre le cancer
dans là dedans je pense à son très
probable qu'on aurait pas de résultats
de recherche vraiment fondamentaux et
qui changerait vraiment la donne en
médecine année c'est très dommage qu'on
explore pratiquement pas à cette piste
parce que c'est pas ça fait pas sérieux
wes des trois sujets que tu arrêtes à ce
sujet le celui de l'allongement de la
durée de vie bonne santé je trouve que
c'est le sujet le plus le plus
intéressant bonjour trompe peut-être
mais parce que notamment il ya des seat
chez nos vols il ya eu sanction
on arrive à convaincre les gens que en
effet ce qu'elle faisait de désirable ça
a conduit vraiment à il ya des choses à
faire pour qu on aille vraiment dans ce
sens ont conduit à notamment en
changeant le financement de la recherche
en biologie en ce cas les domaines de
santé et en plus ça peut avoir des
effets secondaires qui sont pas justes
par exemple si on arrive à est-ce qu'on
hors de la plupart des gens ont déjà
plupart des morts c'est à cause des avc
des concerts mais en plus de ça la prise
en charge de ces personnes a coûté
extrêmement cher c'est en compte des
coûts énormes pour la société donc si on
arrive à exploiter des voix de recharge
qui sont bien au genre du très négligée
taulier allongement de la durée de vie à
la naissance et tout ça ça pourrait
potentiellement conduire à des
découvertes qui réduirait aussi
grandement non seulement la qualité de
vie des personnes âgées mais aussi les
coûts de leur prise en charge
eux c'est ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas
plusieurs chercheurs de haine c'est que
au final par exemple avec le cancer
aujourd'hui on traite les causes et les
conséquences ne connaît pas la cause est
l'e
la cause c'est ce qui fait que premières
cellules cancéreuses d'apparaître
organisé entre autres c'est lié au fait
que l'organisme vix qui est ce qui
augmente la probabilité d'apparition de
cancer avec le temps au moins de ces
naissances également 2 et le fait de
mettre à intéresser un peu plus sur les
questions suite notamment vidéo de
thibaut de me suffit on a fait entendre
que c'est quand même un truc assez très
négligée exploiter c'est une notion
assez importante pour être efficace fait
que quelque chose qui ait négligé le
mérite beaucoup plus notre attention
parce que si c'est négliger ça veut dire
que le fait qu'on s'y intéresse de
bonnes chances de conduire à des
exagérations va pas apprendre la
maîtrise ne fait que je m'écoutais je
suis un peu gêné par exemple un peu gêné
d'en restaurer se fait qu'à ce sera un
peu délicat de défendre l'idée que c'est
une priorité moral de nos modèles en
juillet 2010 à par rapport à d'autres
priorités
mais faites moi l'argument c'est pas
c'est pas tant de dire ça c'est pas
tandis que c'est brutal morale absolue
c'est de dire bon aujourd'hui vont en
suisse par exemple
maintenant même en france ça va quand on
a de quoi manger la plupart des gens de
quoi manger il en voiture ils consomment
plein de trucs inutiles et nouveau
smartphone et compagnie gère dans une
société où tu consommes tellement de
trucs superflu je dis pas que c'est mal
clairement non seulement des trucs qui
vont bien au-delà de nos besoins de base
et dont on n'aurait même pas forcément
besoin pour atteindre un niveau de
bonheur une image plutôt que d'acheter
ces trucs un peu futiles journée des
montres rolex ou pour se valoriser
socialement et des voitures de sport
c'était la consommer des trucs un peu de
sable de riches superflu ont un peu vrai
au moins favoriser davantage des trucs
que me considérer que 10 50 ans et plus
en bonne santé ça infiniment plus de
valeur que peut avoir une rolex une
voiture de ce mois mais aujourd'hui on
dépense à travers la rolex je pense
qu'il ya un argument pour dire que
djezzy entendu roberto yvelines
j'ai eu des élèves des gens un peu et
qui sont de l'altruisme efficace parler
de l'allongement la vie en bonne santé
en particulier les comptes assainis sens
si je pèserai
ou constate également de ce qui bien sûr
et c'est possible que je pense qu'il ya
vraiment un argument à faire pour pour
dire que ça peut être une priorité dans
ce cas ci on réfléchit enfin qu'après
les pieds on voit déjà développés et les
pays en voie de développement pour
éviter ce risque bientôt d'être en
pointe pour aussi il me semble que l'une
des principale cause de souffrance
aujourd'hui on crée une grande cause de
souffrance aujourd'hui dans les pays
développés c'est la sénescence bar à vin
pourrait dire que s'il fait que la
ralentir bas je croise enfants de
l'école mais si on arrive à dire qu'on
peut faire en sorte qu'il y ait plus de
ces naissances au québec vraiment un
autre pas juste c'est clairement dans le
rythme pour faire en sorte qu'en tout
cas ça reste en bonne santé
du coup les gens ne renouerait plus
biologiquement skacel ça conduira ça ça
fait un effet secondaire à l'encontre
fois parce qu'on voulait mais peut-être
qu attaquer sur l'angle vraiment de
moscow bon la souffrance quelque chose
sous sol est très efficace et souvent
très un journal très efficaces sont très
soucieux des pointes des souffrances et
la sénescence consorts le principe parce
qu'à ça m'est déjà arrivé de parler à
quelqu'un d'aborder un peu le sujet et
devoirs en fait que le truc qui faisait
qu'il y avait qu il faisait réagir la
personne était vraiment cette notion de
souffrance des personnes âgées que j'ai
jamais discuté un resto la nouvelle
présidente effective altruisme genève a
requis contre le transit mais ce qu il
me disait que oui le glissement est une
chose négative et ses causes altruisme
efficace de combattre le vieillissement
mais elle est ce qu'elle voudra
idéalement c'est ne pas vieillir mais
mourir brutalement cinq ans histoire
d'avoir une deadline après il ya aussi
des gens qui réfléchissent à comment
mourir la meilleure façon qui soit en
terme de souffrance autant
moi je reçois des coups d'arguments pour
ses besoins c'est à dire ok bien sûr
c'est mieux que vieillir mais si tu dis
pas que tu la conséquence de ça s'écoute
tu vas pas à mourir
eh ben tu auras pas la force pas rater
jours
je comprends un peu
sept ans mention suppose qu'il faut
mourir
mais c'est pas un truc insurmontable
sont pesantes que c'est pas mal un biais
de familiarité moi je ne sais pas
vraiment à presque étonné vieillissement
sans aborder un moment la question oui
mais peut-être que si tu veux vendre ça
l'actrice mais efficace à des gens
n'attriste efficace partir sur le
problème de la souffrance des personnes
âgées ne semblent plus confiants pour
près de cette communauté que partir sur
l'aspect peu que tu veux dire
dans le cas des recherches pour
développer un truc ou livrés plus
vivement qu'il y aurait beaucoup moins d
effets secondaires de en terme de
souffrance du vieillissement et toi
c'est ce genre de recharge sur au
couperet probablement mais l'idée c'est
vraiment il ya énormément d'argent
aujourd'hui dépensées dans la recherche
sur le cancer genre et ça et il ya
peut-être deux voitures sont plus
efficaces qui résoudrait le même
problème que le cancer et d'autre le
fera peut-être mais pas cessé de la vie
de chercheur
après l'interview plus dégueu légiste
pour il me semble que c'est une voie de
recherche négliger ben ouais ouais
effectivement elle a cédé ces naissances
augmente la probabilité la barasse de
l'apparition de la maladie d'alzheimer
et gérard cité demander quels sont les
grands débats au sein du transhumanisme
aujourd'hui entre rencontre entre 36
ministres lors beaucoup parlé à tort
énorme déjà où il yal'histoire
libertariens apa libertarian oui
historiquement du mouvement
transhumaniste bon pour monter un
traitement mais
c'est vraiment développé dans les années
90 dans la silicon valley bien c'est du
coup par effet collatéral ça a été très
libertin rien parce que cette époque en
tout cas c'est moi aujourd'hui mais la
silicon valley des extrêmes en liberté
pendant les deux états d'esprit que
l'état d'esprit les rideaux de machecoul
laisser la liberté d'entreprendre et de
créer une troupe les incroyables ce qui
a pas mal marché dans voici et a du coup
c'était resté sur transhumanistes et
libertariens dans le sens où si c'était
surtout si on a la liberté individuelle
de faire des choses que ce qui est une
cause importante de souffle parce que
par exemple aujourd'hui en france par
exemple bête t'as pas le droit de verser
quand c'est ton adn en france en suisse
je crois qu signe envoyé des moyens pour
contourner mais finalement le pineau
mais cette fois c'est d'ailleurs un
problème qui est pas du tout spécifiques
à des questions transhumanisme ça se
fête regardez comment femme de santé
parce que séquençage de l'adn pour
permettre potentiellement de détecter
des terres du diagnostic médical et on
peut voir le fait de cette interdiction
comme un échec de santé publique qui
font qu'un soir contrebalancer avec tous
les risques aussi que l'on vende part de
la direction des données privées mais je
suis un aspect à quelques chiffres
d'accord avec les libertariens c'est que
si autorisé un truc que le coz de tort à
personne
il n'y a pas de raison de l'intérieur
principes de paris bat pas par exemple
aussi un autre est la cour en france tu
peux pas te faire cryogéniser pas parce
que c'est explicitement interdit parce
que toi que tu es mort ton corps ne pas
partir plus c'est l'impact qui va être
récupérée pour des dons d'organes et
compagnie ce que même s'il ne l'est pas
pour corps appartient à l'état il faut
une fois que tu es mort est interdite
modification de ces étranges comme de
loin tous les arts en france on attend
avec angoisse
c'était dans les années 90 mais c'est un
peu aussi de structurant prochain post
romain de côté donc mon humeur du
progrès technologique et forcément
génial gt200 selon m autrement les
transhumanistes la série qui s'appelle
techno progressiste alors petits points
estime logique qu'en reste t il aux
progressistes les gens pensent que ça
veut dire favorables pour la technique
c'est le progressiste de techno
progressiste à comprendre dans le sens
le même mot progrès ch'ti ce que les
gens les gens qui sont favorables au
mariage gay et compagnie doit être très
social par colas était favorable pour et
social mais dans cette perspective fait
de la même manière que certains votes
favorables au mariage gay je peux pas
être favorable à l'homme au moment de la
durée de vie ont progressé dans notre
vie au progressisme opposition à biot
conservateurs ou retouchés ce qui existe
c'est pour les accidents dans ce sens
elle est à deux balles et de leurs au
final face à transhumanistes plus vous
dire conséquentialiste c'est à dire
prenons par exemple un espèce de données
du troisième maïs par exemple un
traitement qui est longue durée de vie
vous demandez surtout dans quelle mesure
ça va améliorer le bien général de la
fesci vais bien sûr mais de définir le
bien général même est le même partout
coût est favorable à ce programme
technique dans la mesure où ça va
augmenter la qualité de vie des gens
pour par exemple là où tu es contre la
sénescence avons nous pu avoir tous les
problèmes qu'ils utiliseront ce qui
serait arrivé que c'est une cause de mon
sens du bien collectif
du coup il ya des 10 technologies qui
sont assez clairement rejetée par techno
progressiste j'ai pas d'exemples précis
mail à web du coup la grosse différence
avec eux mouvement techno progressive va
y avoir un aspect prise en compte des
risques
si tu te poses la question est-ce qu'une
technologie bonne pour la société
parfois la réponse pas avoir de bons
arguments pour dire que non par exemple
se respecte à temps et transit mais il
se fait par exemple les armes autonome
il y avait des initiatives du turf la
crise titus qui est clairement plein de
troisième à nice
l'apparence est une technologie pour
laquelle pas forcément ils vont être
initiés aussi des arguments pour mettre
les points sur les techno progressistes
sont globalement contre c'est pas ses
parents qui soient pas beaucoup
d'exemples de technologie ou vraiment
content pour moi c'est plus que vous
êtes favorable en tout cas pas opposée à
des régulations oui alors le susurre
crise peur la question on est un peu
lente dans la phase un peu comment les
premières dates facebook c'était super
j'aime bien ça connecte tout le monde
part expliqué christophe kern est donc
c'est une technologie permet d'éditer
tra facilement le génome humain le
problème étant que l'on sait pas trop ce
qu'on habite en tout cas c'est pas
inédite et très facilement les dom et
nous par exemple ça pour être utilisé
pour créer des super virus résistants
petit des vaccins ce sera un problème
possible avec les spurs qui peut
justifier qu'on va eut réglé la même
manière un peu de laisser ce type alors
que je pas du tout écarté ce genre de
risque ce contexte qui se perd par
ailleurs permettra des trucs absolument
fantastique en médecine
trois autres banques ont signalé des
risques et des bénéfices est du coup
assez est ce que jack section se dirige
un peu plus c'est une autre question
d'avoir c est ce que tu penses que ce
genre de réflexion est quelque chose qui
est qui plus qu'avant du coup est ce
qu'on se dirige vers plus de la
réflexion autour de ce qui est
potentiellement un risque que ce qui est
peu tendu assez clairement bénéfique
ballet du mouvement techno progressive
tout ouïe en humaniste déjà apparemment
il ya une augmentation du pourcentage de
nouveaux investissements
mais apparemment cerise sur la majorité
mais celle qui a su forcément le podium
du bon mais cet intérieur de la majorité
des transhumanistes souffleur
apparemment plus de locaux avec nous
qu'on va c'est ce que comme mikel oroz
ils allaient ma sortie avec l'annoncé le
10 et de vieux outils américains
s'appellent james hook qui est vertement
transhumanistes ski aux états unis ne
l'empêchent pas d'être raccord diversité
de bosser dur à trouver suffisante si
l'homme leur a remis ça sur la vie
politique et géographique entre les pros
et 6 2 je pense que des gens comme max
tegmark même si va pas trop du fonction
transhumanistes je pense qu'ils les plus
sceptiques
effectivement ça va beaucoup se parler
le bâtiment où jean en france où la
poussera côté l'état social à voir les
politiques publiques n'est pas un gros
mot en français ça parle plus aux
français qu'on y voir des gens je dis
bien si les gens les plus libres
mais la joie notre désaccord qui a un
petit peu lisse alors autant tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire dans mon
transhumanistes khouildi là va
automatiser beaucoup de boue qui
existent oui autant il ya un désaccord
sur ce que ça va faire des choix
technologiques à ce qu'il y ait de
nouveaux emplois seront créés parce que
ça a du sens ce monde et
technologiquement pour être compétitif
face à la machine mais disons un peu
alexandre
là où il ya beaucoup de débats parfois
du chômage technologies qu'il faut pour
apporter des solutions qui profite à
jour si on veut laisser mon sens les sa
batterie et pense que c'était l'année où
chantent les terriens que quoi qu'il
arrive il y aura toujours l'hérault
création d'emplois je suis et parce que
je suis je pas d'accord avec ça mais ce
qui a été à côté un peu à peu comme dire
les marchés s'autorégulent quoi qu'il
arrive sur un texte que ça a été le cas
une certaine époque où est né s'étaient
introduits dès que j'ai vraiment
destructive
l'album n'est plus la même et en faire
la réflexion on va parler un petit peu
de tout ça aussi dans le cas précédent
avec avec gildas chêne doré cas de
chômage
je vends donc non à ses proches de ses
le quai fully donc l'auteur du bouquin
yach superpowers entrepreneurs chinois
la jeunesse des cités associés parce que
quand à leurs envies blason pas toujours
quand espèce de schiste qui fait leur
devoir apprendre à dégelis vraiment pas
la décrire kai-fu lee
cessons de regarder un cliché de weedon
masques chinois vous c'est qu'il écrit
plein d'entreprises qui a fait une thèse
en intelligence artificielle je crois
qu'il va inventer généré énormément de
revenus d'entreprise de sa carrière qui
a connu un capitaliste entrepreneurs ne
sais pas le candidat américain andrew
yang qui est favorable à ce prix qu'ils
sont définis clairement comme un
capitaliste il avant de faire de la
politique c'est aventure capitaliste pas
de le voir d'une base et poitiers fêter
ses 10 ans gagnent d'ailleurs peut très
bien être très capitaliste et pour
l'europe
du coup ça conclut les utilisent pour
but de servir
on peut aussi être à gauche et frappe à
l'heure dite choquée c'est génial enfin
ce qui met d'accord
la gauche va mettre ma chronique et à
mettre en valeur de base
d'autres débats importants dans son du
transhumanisme j'ai terminé c'est
important contre comme par des genres
des des nations comme va le quément but
à la viande artificielle ses
descriptions discuté au sein du
transhumanisme mieux a revu leur
position que consomme au contenu et à
résister
globalement les gens sont très en faveur
de services et transmission a priori tu
vas pas avoir de valeur dans le vrai
vaches naturel parce qu'il veut aller
ses membres du coup est-ce que tu
finiras quasiment le transhumanisme
comme la lutte contre le biais du
naturisme c'est qu'à moi c'est la fée
condition nécessaire mais pas suffisant
peut plus clairement mais ça semble
difficile des transhumanistes aussi tuer
ses rangs l'attention que j'ai
l'impression que c'est vraiment la
tension entre ceux qui qui ceux qui se
disent trans humaniste et ceux qui
critiquent le transhumanisme il y avoir
dans cette tension au niveau de ce qui
est naturel et sain
ainsi vous y vont être un peu naturistes
qui pourquoi blessures reçues par
exemple des gens qui vont être prêt à
envisager des technologies
transhumanistes complètement
vertigineuse mais d'un autre côté je
surtout pas à réformer le système
économique au châble et ceara côté de
faire des comédiens dany magloire tu
peux pas
informations économiques as assez mais
c'est intéressant ça c'est quand ça fait
assez longtemps que je peux sauter pas
mal de questions pour arriver à des
questions peu plus vers la fin quand tu
vois le futur du transhumanisme je suis
trop vieux pour voir le futur [ __ ] est
nouvelle mais probablement sur quoi tu
parles et des bas mais je vais finir la
question parce que parler vrai de la
question close so souvent bon il ya il
ya eu quelques transhumanistes quelques
posthumanisme unique édition qui est qui
m'énerve c'est qu'en pensez vous qu'il y
aura telle technologie
c'est comme des déjà le marine date
c'est pas une bonne approche ou plutôt
faire comme dans la vidéo sur des
probabilités côté il y avait les mêmes
mais elles savent faire des prédictions
justement faire des prédictions
ça m'intéresse pas plus que ça elle me
dit ça m'intéresse parler par exemple
dans le cas de le dire parce que des
prédictions à des impacts concrets sur
ce qu'on doit faire aujourd'hui
si c'est juste pour vous technoprophètes
quand tu vois le futur du mouvement
fondé les gens des idées étranges
sioniste bas de base pâtes rare aux
forces contraires les seconds entendant
cette époque où il ya beaucoup de gens
il était monté populisme des gens qui
m'ont espèce de droit de remplir
traditionalistes donc les qui pour faire
un film avec un certain rejet de la
perspective d'un passant qui a plus de
rejet de la technologie font des
technologies en général mes choix en
tout cas que c'est si on va vers une
dégradation de la situation économique
il y aura seulement entraîné plus d'anti
vaccins un truc comme ça mais
si plus de chance par la technologie les
plus technophiles dans des périodes de
ces données on voit les bons aspects de
la technologie mais laissés pour compte
il ya peut-être une opposition entre ce
qui se passe en europe aux états unis et
puis ce qui se passe en chine
et puis on voit développement où les
technologies de toucher à ce mot tourner
encore il se trouve que la chine ait
encore quelques années dans son influx
de croissance à deux chiffres je crois
que sa croissance à un chiffre
ça commence à stagner comme en europe je
pense qu'il aura des phénomènes
c'est la même si on est aussi une
opposition assez récurrente entre
technologies et ressources
oui mais ça s'est bien passé
comment concilier la côte et les
transhumanistes mais comment récurent
spicy président et de salubrité
incroyable et d'autre part les
connaisseurs qui après l'effondrement
complet des civilisations c'est un peu
con famille soit je suis pas qualifié
pour parler de ce lobby mais c'est vrai
que imaginant un scénario ultra mauvais
du réchauffement climatique ça chauffe
vraiment vite et beaucoup est sûre ça va
pas tuer tous les humains mais ça va
entraîner ou des déplacements de
populations de crise de problème la
culture et c'est super propice à la
technophilie facilement imaginer des
centrales par réaction un équivalent
écolo de l'état islamique du risban ça
sera une erreur de faire moins confiance
en technologie parce que la situation
actuelle en tout cas ce réflexe
d'auditions ce n'est clairement pas
c'est pas une réflexion rationnelle
repoussée
elle imite le soleil fréquenta
technologies disponibles pour de bonnes
raisons mais ont été réfléchies et
clairement sera pas le cas la majeure
partie des gens qui vont s'énerver comme
ouais c'est ça que ça a été un côté un
peu à peu plus dans le sens où au lieu
d'une certaine manière c'est d'amener
les gens à un état d'esprit où il serait
pas forcément transhumanisme et ouvert
d'esprit receveur d'idées mais les
forces contraires sont beaucoup plus
importants donc je suis pas trop triste
ouais on peut parler peut-être
rapidement de la manière dont le
transhumanisme et des qui est écrit on
va dire que dans les médias ainsi que je
pense mais je pense me montra france et
d'ailleurs obligé d impression que c'est
aux états unis tu as comme des cônes
ultraconservateur dividendes et
communautaires en plus anti avortement à
fond et tous les jeux
je pense que s'ils sortent pas lu les
jours qu'un troisième a nice c'est plus
parce qu'ils sont une belle victoire de
beule qui s'entendent même pas parlé à
tanger me disent pourtant pas massicotte
vallée où les trésors à ce genre d'idée
si c'est le collisionneur sa place
baisse encore plus mal quand ce genre en
france on avait souhaité république et
tous étaient d'accord qu'il y avait un
début de polémique sur le voile et
compagnie qui n'existe pas aux états
unis parce que comme dieu en france il
faut qu'on essaie de faire pousser
pareils qu'on se mette tous d'accord oui
il ya beaucoup plus de débats sur des
sujets de société parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'il faut qu'on soit tous
course contre le tribalisme
c'est néfaste
c'est compliqué parce que d'un côté je
trouve que c'est bien d'avoir un sens
social qui existe en france qui n'existe
pas aux états unis fera sens de la
collectivité
ben quoi nous serons individuellement
aussi considérer qu'il ya plein de ceux
pour lesquels les gens qu'ils aiment ils
font les gens qui n'aiment pas ils font
planer un peu à côté
il pense qu'il agisse des milieux
uniforme alors on n'est pas obligé de
porter toujours le même uniforme on peut
cohabiter avec des gens qui ont des
idées différentes
au moins pour se poursuivre et du veau
le transhumanisme sponsors maroni dans
les médias régulièrement ses serments un
sujet principal
mais évidemment t2c sur le
transhumanisme ça ça fait un peu
d'intelligence artificielle web à
l'immense majorité des intervenants sur
le trentin des transhumanistes l'oeuvre
en france sont extrêmement critiques du
transhumanisme par endroits et mes skis
parce qu'ils ne sont mon avis de ramener
ce réseau va parler dont il faut il faut
l'aider des pamphlets décroît disque
ouvre sa menace de notre humanité mais
plutôt très humain que le transférer au
6 même être qu être outre avec
désarmement c'est un truc assez
transhumanistes pour ce qui n'est pas de
se faire dire des choses ou dans une
manif qui me dit que des gens pourraient
effectivement dire mais que je connais
comme on pratique du coup est ce que j
avais d réfléchi à comment inverser la
tendance et des stratégies en tête basse
et j'avais encore cessé de faire des
trucs à notre petite échelle ne jouant
pas nombreux par exemple un vrai sens je
m'étais amusé à faire un article sur le
site
c'est son prix du maïs des intervenants
titre a souvent fait pour pas être
transhumanisme certain jacques testart
biologiste qui avait bossé sur l'un des
premiers bébés éprouvettes et qui nous
fuyait cra contre ce genre de truc mais
nous allons la gagner une conférence à
lui est né ce récemment les
scientifiques ont fait 3 à l'humanisme
est sûre si le 3 humanisme c'était
augmenter nos capacités humaines par
exemple tendance paraît tout à l'heure
la haine là bien sûr ce serait bien mais
ce n'est pas ce que veulent les
transhumanistes c'est déjà si ensuite on
va aller en supprimant les troisièmes à
10,2 il va le mettre et de métal dans le
corps parce qu'ils sont des bronzés qui
détestent lors que leur corps et leur
seul profit la limite s'ils parlaient
que des transhumanistes américain dans
sa c6 est décidé que le concert pas mais
à la limite vous d'action pure mais même
les transhumanistes américain ultra
libéraux ne veulent pas juste
l'avion suisse pour 2010 énormément de
cicatrisation du transit mais je pense
que le raisonnement tenait aussi je me
suis fait une bonne guerre que ça veut
dire que c'est évident que c'est mal il
conseille donc c'est à l'étape se
maintenant à l'étape
les cours se fait-il que des gens sont
assez fous pour être favorable à ça donc
c'est parce qu'ils ont fait a dénoncé
lui d'accord ils sont que parce que
l'état paie déjà expliqué pourquoi c'est
mal et ensuite éventuellement on pourra
faire de psychologie
mais la bataille n'est pas démontré
pourquoi c'est mal et une étape donc
comprenez que le rationalisme très
mauvaise connotation dans les médias
classiques
peine perdue si d'éviter par étrange
manège mais paraît directement de
l'allongement
de la vie en bonne santé des sujets
vraiment un peu zappé en biais enfin
débat le débat on est 3e à 10 sur le
rappel de tim howard a frappé ce modèle
apporte des emmerdes souhaite aller en
douceur mais alors je suis père à
l'elysée - arguments pour les dégâts
causés
elle n'a pas déjà les arguments contre
c'est que ce qui manque c'est maintenant
le mot transhumanistes doigt le fait que
ça termine en lice mais ça sonne comme
communisme fascisme ultralibéralisme
l'humanise d'enseignement agricole alice
mais c'est le disque destiné à
rapprocher ça c'est sûr le paysagisme
qu'il faudrait pas va pas être brisée
mise plutôt bien si je tenais à trois
mois est ce que ce bannissement façon
très négative dans les médias puisque
personne en parle dans la manière
d'améliorer un peu difficile s'intéresse
à ces questions qui s'était mis que des
gens qui vont être rappelés pour des
raisons c'est une réflexion c'est que je
transmets avait déjà une promo sera que
du couteau rappelle une autre en
humanisme l'est déjà
même si tu n'utilises pas accusera
lettres écoutes visant à passer ton
temps à raser les murs way2many
s'entendait raison à la loterie parce
que si tu es que c'est un peu un peu bel
exemple de manque par exemple la tup
esquiver a été supérieur à ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment me faire aller
dans la mer bleue transit pas se régler
les gens aiment bien catalogué mais
c'est sympa par a relayé le biologiste
miroslav radman a qui travaillent sur
l'allongement de durée de vie
d'ailleurs bon en gros l'astuce qui
trouve pour éviter la belle affamant
transhumanistes c'est comme ça
chercheurs ça pourrait le gêner
peut-être faire est de redéfinir un
troisième à nice mme comme des nids ce
moment-là participent organisation et
ailleurs qui s'intéressent à la partie
biologique et d'original mexique donc ça
englobe prendre la liste dira non
j'étais pas prôner la liste s'est
modifié la définition histoire de
pouvoir dire qu'on ne naît pas et donc
d'éviter puijila qui licencient ou
encore oasis a vraiment des chercheurs
alors chercheur ne serait pas dans leurs
attaques et les arguments pour utiliser
le mot c'est que déjà quoi qu'on fasse
mouche sera utilisée ensuite aux graves
qui notent même utiliser gmail ou
transhumanisme ait channel et ont
convenu d'un contrat un troisième à nice
plus immédiatement pour une enquête
c'est rikers elle dilue le pacte du
transhumanisme grand-chose rationnelle
des transhumanistes parce que c deja
quand même comme troisième est dispo sur
surtout a eu ce mot sera guidé discuter
dans les médias parce qu'il soit utilisé
que des gens de toute la défense ont
réclamé bas niveau ce soit des gens
plutôt raisonnable que des gens un peu
un peu fou et qui se met des dividendes
on sait pas quoi raconter il crée à
masisi dans les blés vivent donc la
majorité des gens par exemple c'est son
transhumanistes des gens qui sera quand
même des transhumanistes qui est qui
reste jeune et sympathique
personnellement pas si votre chouchou
serviront encore plus de caractère que
s'il sert viendra donner si le fait que
de toute façon c'est aussi un truc pour
avoir de la visibilité médiatique parce
qu'un club comme les gens bons rails
pour menus médiévaux faire des décès sur
le transhumanisme intervalles de temps
réguliers quoi qu'il arrive et que y'a
un moment ils vont se dire on se serait
pas mal qu'on a des gens qui sont ces
empreintes d'humanisme
je respecte les gens qui ne devraient
pas utiliser où il est personnellement
je préfère assumer quoi parler devant
alexandre parce que c'est un peu le
monsieur transhumanisme en france c'est
beau quand les médias veulent pas être
rose humanisme d'abord il essaie
d'inventer laurent alexandre bon bien
sûr il arrive pas toujours parce qu'il
est extrêmement demandés et c'est
d'abord la vidéo alexandre et ensuite
éventuellement d'autres personnes et aux
coudres du coup laurent alexandre est ce
que ça te fait plaisir et histoire
l'autre est entendue transhumanisme dans
les médias s'exprimant ce que lui se
défend de n'être gens pour échapper à la
diabolisation 10 ont subi à
l'éclairement il a une attitude papa tu
rases aux sujets qu'ils essaient de
jouer sur tous les tableaux à la fois
pour tirer les bénéfices de total de nos
qui tire les bénéfices d'être considéré
comme haut représentant du
transhumanisme en france le sait pas qu
un truc comme ça m'apporte des combats
commencent à lui reprocher d'être utile
à dire ah mais c'est un moyen ça se fait
ça c'est les transhumanistes et les
transhumanistes là et commence à te
brosser un portrait transhumanistes de
la silicon valley pareil qu'il attend le
même temps le portrait que les gens qui
se rencontrent le transhumanisme et
ultra caricatural qui sont des gens de
son âge physique des murs génique qui va
mettre des puces dans le cerveau de nos
enfants
je peux même pas l'hymne god hates tu
fais une complication des citations des
pires situations des pires
transhumanistes plus bricoler un
portrait un peu comme ça mais c'est
clairement malhonnête de dire que c'est
représentatif
même si on se restreint au grand
humaniste silicon valley facilement
crackable rhétorique très récurrentes et
pas du tout spécifique au transformisme
a essayé de peindre un portrait d'un
truc horrible c'est tout ce que fait il
y aura devrait tomber à le faire bien
sûr quand on est content ça apporterait
ma femme en est que l'on s'intéresse aux
contres donc elle n'aura l'ex ans est
issue parce que clairement il dit
défavorable à pas mal de trucs
transhumanistes on va dire qu'on opprime
et auront enfin il suggère de faire des
trucs que personnellement je ne trouve
pas trace sympathique mais en même temps
il se sert de cette caricature de
transhumanistes imaginaire complètement
fou pour dire pour faire un peu le bon
film avait écrit ok ce que je propose ça
pas très agréable mais en face à
l'étranger blida et si comme valeo cité
tard et donc moi je suis bon fils que
c'est le méchant pic du coup à accepter
les machins encore au final les trucs
qu'ils proposent sont plus hardcore que
je te propose les trans ministre du
koweit s'arrêter dans une vidéo récente
mais même s'il se dit pas a priori on
pourrait penser il a plutôt entendu 30
ministres qui participe plus à perdre
une mauvaise passe e3 humanisme parsons
à grande audience que des gens qui sont
ouvertement contre est-ce que autant les
gens qui sont confiées aux gestionnaires
des arguments contre parce que ce sont
des arguments alors que nuit il peut il
va fournir aux gens qu'ils sont comptés
espèce de repoussoir dont ils ont besoin
pour pour aligner les rangs
est-ce que je pense même que en parlant
ainsi amener des gens à s'intéresser aux
transhumanisme très négatif
peut-être à la place bajaj battre au
truc à eux reprochés à l'époque de son
premier livre la mort de la mort que ça
parlait surtout de façon assez
descriptive avec les quelques réflexions
et des formes grand chose que nationale
surtout pas pas d'accord depuis qu'il a
fait son livre la guerre des
intelligences a cependant expliqué
pourquoi je suis je peux d'accord mais
qui en gros il ya cette idée
par ailleurs dans une interview à sion
sur machination de complémentarité avec
l'intelligence artificielle ou mon rôle
de le france d'humanisme ce serait utile
qu'on ferait pas parce qu'on pousse à
bien ou positif où elle tenait ce soit
mais pour tenir la compétition avec à la
fois avec la chine et avec les
intelligences artificielles donc c'est
vrai trois ministres n'a pas envie de le
faire mais tu vas être forcé de le faire
en plus grands on va le tirer par les
cheveux
ça me dégoûte et tu sera forcé de l'aso
situé super tu vas crever clairement
vers en termes de psychologie inversée
c'est catastrophique parce que du côté
du volant qui n'ont pas le choix de
faire un truc quand bien même ce serait
le rêve des soucis de cette manière là
ultra muriel mieux pour donner envie de
sortir
il faut que les porsche la discussion
que j'ai eue premier épisode de
probablement avec ivan mental où il
disait à peu près la même chose des
sceptiques hardcore qui est s'avère en
effet ça prend ça sans doute un effet
très contre-productif
ce sauf que dans le cas des faits petit
plat de la forme je suis d'accord avec
le nouvel moi et mes deux scientifiques
c'est mieux que vous dites que mais
lâche même pas d'accord avec le fond
dans ce sens inverse
en gros il est radicalement radicalement
opposées au repli de basse parce que
parce que si on a rentré les
dictionnaires aux petites bases on va
complètement ramolli
je sais c'est qu'en version de décadence
qu'en gros qu'eux on pense à un
effondrement de l'empiré enrôler les
romans il faisait des orgies et des
partouzes et du coup et se sont abolies
l'empiré romain s'est effondré
et si on a lors du débat soit enfin
mettre un peu comme dans le film will
meet a vu le total film c'est un film
avec le petit depuis c'est avec un petit
robot est un moment inédit que sont
devenus les humains parce qu'on vous l'a
été a complètement pollué sont marquées
dans l'espace et unia qui gère plus on
le vaisseau ils sont les obèses dans un
ancien les appuie sur un bouton pour
avoir à manger
sam euros c'est beaucoup d'heures aux
fins de prison parce que c'est ma sinon
des assistés de ligne a dont on devra
comme ça et encore une fois je pense que
les précédents est en manque
d'imagination par rapport à mai et
surtout pas l idée que ou comme on veut
forcément invité ça parce que ce serait
horrible
il faut absolument continuer à soit en
positif sur le marché du travail même si
c'est possible si vous aimez question
est joe ce sera dangereux qu'il faut
qu'on se serve bien aligner le scénario
chômage technologique
je n'ai pas quelle probabilité 100% mais
juste refusé d'envisager un scénario
simplement on n'arriverait pas à faire
graver tout sur marché de travail de
courant refusé d'envisager des solutions
qu'on pourrait imaginer dans ce cas là
et c'est dangereux parce que si ce
scénario se produit dans le genre en
risque de plein et les gens qui
n'arriveront pas à trouver du boulot
parce que on a fait plein de la
formation 3 complètement terminée on
approche de la fin
ce que tu pourrais quel message clé que
tu voudras que les joueurs les auditeurs
thien ah ouais ça vous tous simples pour
synthétiser
des trucs dont on a parlé c'est
peut-être qu'il ya des gens parmi les
auditeurs quand ils entendent le mot
transhumanisme tout de suite à savoir
hérisse le poil et sap en mode combat ça
sent que ça que ça attaque des valeurs
qui sont importantes pour eux du coup ça
amène à déjà débattre avec beaucoup de
virulence avait beaucoup de lyrisme
comment et surtout à chercher les
raisons d'être contre à tout prix ça
c'est un peu un truc que tu as pu
expérimenter avec thibault sur la laguna
du réduit qui est quand même un sujet
que je trouve relativement soft que
c'est pareil on parle pas de mettre des
plus dans le sable que vrai que sur ce
sujet relativement inoffensif par
l'objet de vivre 50 ans de plus en bonne
santé et vont aller chercher des raisons
d'aborder des raisons qui sont assez
pertinente
est ce que ça va faire la surpopulation
est ce que j'ai en main son billet ok
mais ensuite ça de chercher des raisons
vous père tirée par les cheveux
on va voir on cherchait dans un quart
des bas visuellement sur aucun au-dessus
mal sentiment que c'est que c'est
mauvais et puis vide il faut que je
trouve au cerveau se met en mode
moulinette pour trouver une toutes les
raisons possibles imaginables d'être
contre du corps si vous utilisez ce
genre de match on vous invite au calme
et prenez une premiers tees and sex and
her millions de personnes et je pense
qu'on peut se mettre d'accord sur le
fait que quand on aborde un sujet avec
un état d'esprit avec la tête chaude
on a pas mal de chance de dire des corps
et donc si on va aborder ce sujet
important qu'on soit pour ou contre bien
il faut déjà commencer par essayer de le
faire la tête froide avec des arguments
opposés très bon ensuite je pense qu'on
peut être pas d'accord sur le fait que
on sera d'accord la course le
conséquences et nice france rte qui peut
faire relativement consensus et en
parler aux gens je pense que pas mal de
gens sont d'accord pour dire que par ce
code
si des principes déontologiques entre
clairement compter avec des conséquences
positives ou pousse à faire des tripes
dans les conséquences des actifs non on
peut dire que au moins de l'écologie
n'est pas suffisante
au moins il ya une tension est un peu
conséquentialiste sans être sans
conséquence réalisme en tout cas si on
est conséquent ces listes du coup il
voit plutôt envisager plutôt envisagé
comme ça c'est de se dire voilà à
prendre une technologie transit de
données
quels sont les risques quels sont les
bénéfices potentiels
voici ces blocs aux passionnés et
ensuite laquelle la question qu'il faut
se poser c'est toujours est-ce que c'est
souhaitable et c'est bizarre parce que
c'est sûr énormément sujet on se demande
toujours si c'est souhaitable parce que
ça semble cependant la question
important que vous sur transhumanistes
leurs racines beaucoup de gens ne
finisse pas le raisonnement qui s'arrête
en gros deux roule sur le troisième à
nice mme d une attaque aux valeurs
fondamentales humaine
oui peut-être mais où peut-être pas mais
termine ton raisonnement campc mal
trois listes sont nombreuses et
peut-être admettons mais peut-être
qu'ils sont ces détails à 90% mais ça ne
dit pas en quoi le transit des essais
des régions de façon calme et posée
surtout qu'à regarder toujours en vue la
question est-ce que c'est souhaitable
c'est des amis même si les gens
cette scène dérange moins que les gens
soient compte que les gens disent qu'ils
sont content pour de mauvaises raisons
et initie son compte avec des arguments
à qu'on peut avoir un vrai débat
quand comme on en a sur pas mal de
sujets au fond ce sera déjà une grande
amélioration parce que aujourd'hui
globalement le débat est un petit peu
empêché ou polluée par plein partagera
c'est vraiment sujet sur lequel on a
tendance à mal les battre allez voir les
vidéos de séances où roulent sur hashtag
des bâtons nul je pense que ce n'est pas
ce sera d effet collatéral très positif
sur le transhumanisme mais si vous êtes
d'accord avec ses idéaux des bateaux
mieux vous débattre et munich re rémy
nice mais je pense que dans beaucoup de
cas quand on essaie de mieux débattre
ben je remarque que dans la plupart des
cas on est davantage
je pense que je pense que la priorité du
transhumanisme aujourd'hui c'est de
pouvoir et c'est ce qu'ont observé vidéo
sur pas mal de trucs sur amènera à nous
débattions transhumanistes que ceux qui
quittent pas son nom de domaine est mal
que ça mais papa j'ai aussi on est pour
le transmettre
c'est important de les battre mais on
n'a pas besoin d'être défendus transmise
pour vous défendre l'idée de débattre
tout va plutôt que d'aller se confronter
des points de vue très différents à des
gens qui n'y a pas d'accord sur des
souris plus fondamentaux comme disait
déjà amené les gens à avoir le même état
d'esprit que soient ses parts pour ces
conditions pas suivant bien sûr mais
c'est bien je pense et condition
nécessaire pour éventuellement qui sont
davantage que moi avoue transit manie
sme et en particulier c'est
effectivement mieux d'être aussi que ça
consiste
et du coup bah merci aux votations c'est
un super message est ce que tu peux
maintenant finir avec deux
recommandations de vidéos de podcasts de
livres des personnes suivant c'était
forcément parce qu'avant jean-yves 3 que
du malade
pouvoir aller l'impression que je vais
devoir changer at à trois points et
gilles aussi la chaîne rica a demandé
trois jours où j'ai eu mal échelonnés
entre les troubles dans ces trois livres
en anglais désolé pour les ventes y
apprenez l'anglais c'est un bon
investissement
alors par lequel commencer donc ces
trois livres dont seulement un rapport
véhicules transhumanistes qui ne me
quitte pas règles de la même manière
qu'au mieux des maths peut avoir un
impact de 3 gears est libre a un impact
indirect sur la manière dont il a
dépensé 3 humanisme premier cd il faut
que tu connais je pensais promet c'est
the righteous mind
c'est un livre de psychologie morales
lors c'est un domaine assez pelletier
donc sans rose est la psychologie de la
manière dont construisant des
raisonnements moreau hongrois pour faire
court je peux pas trop m'étaler sur
l'île mais si vous êtes disons non
politisée à gauche ou à droite ou à
gauche l'autre à droite c'est que vous
avez tendance à penser que le conduit
dans ça c'est mauvais une diabolique ou
que s'ils menacent notre démocratie qui
doit être combattu férocement lisez ce
livre parce que ça cesse et expliqueront
les mécanismes psychologiques qu'il ya
derrière ces histoires c'est un [ __ ]
que les gens n'aiment pas un peu de
tribalisme de polarisation de groupe
comment on construit une morale de aussi
le fait que parfois le dialogue ne se
rend pas compte que le dialogue est très
difficile parce que les gens n'ont pas
les mêmes actions moreau mais par
exemple
des gens qui va porter accordé
uniquement de l'importance aux où elle
faire qu'au bien-être que nous devons
accorder de l'importance à des trucs
plus abstraits comme la sacralité le
côté transgressif du transhumanisme peut
être des envies de ce point de vue ouais
d'accord ou non en mairie ce n'était
qu'à prendre en compte dans sa réflexion
est candidat avec avec des gens que ça
sert à ça ça ne discute pas en gros
quand j'ai filmé diverses google s'est
dit ah je comprends mieux pourquoi les a
fait ça sa série sur un nom c'est un
livre passionnant que leurs grandes qui
fait beaucoup réfléchir sur sur une
manière sur toutes les valeurs qu'on a
et qu on les défend beaucoup de
phénomènes de nom alors si vous aimez si
vous avez pendant une chanson ce soir à
cannes c'est estimant de pas mal de gens
qui l'écoutent sur votre fils facebook à
partager plein de vidéos énervé si on
est les emplois et du camp d'en face que
soient les fascistes contre il ya les
quelques lignes de gauche féministe en
partageant l'épilepsie un extrait
possible pour avoir plein de mecs de
gens qui vous dire ça mais c'est
vraiment arrêt il faut combattre
mais pour symboliser ce livre vous aurez
sans doute beaucoup moins envie de le
faire il y aura de deuxième livre s'est
séparé que ça peut être pas tort d'entre
eux m'a dit ça de ce dictateur handbook
je suis la vie du g20 peuvent déjà voir
la vidéo de 6 gilles picard qui
s'appelle roule son honneur des sous
titres français
voilà ce que j'ai vu cette vidéo je
l'avais trouvé très très cool mais en
même temps j'étais pas totalement
convaincu parce que dans la vidéo c'est
ça semble assez abstrait moins d'énergie
pour expliquer de quoi ça parle ça
explique que la le pouvoir politique
sous l'angle de la théorie du jeu
déjeuner ou en balayant d'entrée l'idée
que c'est si les dictateurs font des
trucs horribles comme
l'éditeur africain c'est pas parce
qu'ils sont méchants ou en peut-être
qu'ils sont méchants au point c'est pas
ça qui apporte ce qui importe c'est que
ce qu'ils font et qui semble leur il
s'est malheureusement dans le contexte
risson de la stratégie quasi optimales
pour rester au pouvoir
bien sûr il pourrait faire des trucs
plus positif que ce serait sa manoeuvre
est sans doute leur position au pouvoir
et du coup ça explique pourquoi c'est
des gens qui essaie d'écrire votre
positif chez ces quelques exemples dans
le livre elles sont rapidement remplacés
par des gens qui ont à faire des
victimes alkyl stratégie négative est
cruelle celle de par ailleurs et bien
des dictateurs africains qu'on présente
comme les deux tyrans sanguinaires moi
il ya un motif ou ça qu'ils ont un côté
un peu fou mais bon peut être à avoir ce
côté fou tout en étant un génie de la
politique pour sûr considère que la
politique c'est la science de comment
rester au pouvoir et ses dictateurs
africains qui parfois complètement taré
ils sont fatigués quand il dit de livres
ah ouais ça en fait c'est jean rex
c'est maintenant que se répandre en lice
par rapport à la vidéo c'est des tonnes
et des tonnes des tonnes d'exemples à
toutes les époques sur tous les
continents
ok je disais livre j'ai vu que j'étais
beaucoup plus convaincus de cette avance
était pas trop quand même vu leur site
et moi aussi beaucoup plus convaincus
après avoir lu le livre lui d'autres
trucs de mesquita métier ce livre c'est
vraiment cessé plus tard il reconnaît
que ses héros mesquita voyait il y avait
qu un autre auteur qui travaille dans le
même labo de recherche je crois pas
qu'ils voient ça c'est un ado de
sciences politiques le sou selon la
théorie des jeux comme une petite équipe
de recherche et une version pu égaliser
2-2 plein de papiers de recherche qui
l'a publié vraiment dans des trains
desservant des trucs des résultats de
recherche est assez documenté avec avec
des données et tout ça c'est pas juste
un type à qui la qualité qui a rejoint
il ya une théorie comme ça c'est très
bien documenté et donc en particulier
avec par exemple historique
le livre
m en particulier si on peut revenir un
truc de ça c'est si vous êtes du genre à
peu importe rocher droite de gauche ou à
avoir envie de voter pour un politicien
en particulier parce que c'est l'homme
providentiel a compris providentiel
c'est quelqu'un qui a des valeurs qui va
redresser le pays parce qu'il sait ce
qui est bien pour le peuple ne le fait
pas mais surtout pas vous posez vous la
question va il faut surtout pas partir
du principe qu'un politicien à faire des
trucs dans l'intérêt du peuple parce
qu'il est gentil ou qu'il ya des malgré
eux mêmes et même s'il en a un qui n'en
avait que le fdg petit mal pour rester
au pouvoir c'était de faire des trucs
qui m'ont backhaul avoir tendance à
perquie gros et inversement
aussi dans l'idée dé tout cas ceux des
raisons d'espérer par exemple du ghana
en afrique où c'est un pays où c'est un
peu à part ou avant c'était une
dictature horrible comme en trouve plein
en afrique et qui s'est beaucoup
améliorée que c'est beaucoup beaucoup
plus propre que les pays occidentaux
bien sûr ce sera parfait mais tout en
gardant le même dirigeant pouvoir qui
est créatif qu'on a pu prêter des
dictateurs sanguinaires qui maintenant
est ce que met ce qu'il appelle un
relooking démocrate ses dangers dès
lundi qu'ils étaient forcés à être
démocrate par l'acceptation de son pays
c'est bien ce que ça veut dire qu'il n'y
a pas besoin de dégager un accord coupé
la tête c'est la menace du change et des
incentive à l'utilisateur mais en
démocratie donc du coin c'est si vous
voulez que si vous élisez quelqu'un
pensait surtout à est ce que cette
personne va être contrainte avec un
flingue sur la tempe
c'est une métaphore bien besoin d'avoir
un pape mais ce que m est-ce qu'elle va
vraiment avoir le couteau sous la gorge
pour agir à peu près bien dans le sens
de l'intérêt de la population
si c'est pas le cas
ac je suis un grand fan de mesquita je
trouve ça dommage d arc et qui ait pas
plus de gens qui parlent de mesquita ces
petites vidéos de youtube finalement
promet ce critère mais c'est vrai que
ces idées au bac ont changé classement
choix politique mais je sais un peu nos
âges qui laisse est stable depuis
l'élection de trump vient me voir ce
qu'il en pense
les derniers libre et sans a parlé aussi
c'est ea et superpowers donc écrit par
une telle foule il adore chinois très
connu en chine qui a les deux servantes
rendre intéressant dans une première
partie séparée du reste il explique
comment se passe le et à et game un film
qui s'appelle le china est haïe par
allied universe que l'univers parallèle
de la filière es tunis a dit ah ouais
c'est vrai un univers parallèle où tout
est toujours équivalent de google et
compagnie mais c'est pas juste des
équivalents chinois c c'est eux qui sont
en train de muter pour devenir à la base
c'était des copies de google et aubry
ils sont en train de muter pour devenir
des trucs très différents dans un fond
ce beaucoup plus moderne et avancer que
ce qu'on peut trouver en occident et
dont on n'a pas confiance parce que
c'est ça à port anna permet de séparer
je pense que oui des décennies même
années à venir la chine pourrait devenir
vous même et déjà technologiquement
beaucoup plus avancé que l'occident où
on a plein sa compagne blocage par
rapport à août et que par exemple la
ville chinoise où 99% des paiements vont
se faire avec des qr codes sur
smartphone comme j'imagine mal sa passe
et aux états unis à ce que les gens
aiment bien avoir des dollars américains
comparé ses fils détails sur ces aspects
la chine est largement au dessus
c'est ça que jusque là
l'épée qui gagnait dans la compétition
économique c'était les payer plutôt
capitaliste comme les états unis en
particulier la californie parce que dans
le contexte des décennies précédentes
il a été protégé le p'tit bal avec ce
côté assez dérégulé pas trop d'état mais
dans le contexte avec l'irb dans le fait
que la chine n'est que pour lachine à
voir par exemple des projets
gouvernement des gros projets
gouvernementaux avec plusieurs milliards
sur l'ia de la chine c'est pas un gros
mot c'est un état centralisé pour de
bonnes et de mauvaises raisons ces
poèmes tellement leur donner un avantage
compétitif par rapport aux états unis et
alors alexandre parle de guerre des
intelligences artificielles mais je sais
pas si c'est une guerre en tout cas les
films pourraient avoir un gros avantage
compétitif sur les états unis
précisément parce que les capable
d'avoir des politiques publiques
d'intelligence artificielle
ce dont on s'est rendus incapables les
aides à la pierre et peut-être aussi
pour le meilleur
c'est compliqué handica sa chance et si
fait un lien avec le livre précédent
c'était très peur en fit ce que ok là
aujourd'hui une récitation actuelle
l'intérêt du gouvernement chinois
c'est plutôt d'investir en sa population
c'est à dire faire en sorte qu'ils sont
effacées des universitaires gagner leur
vie et compagnie mais si la situation
change avec l'ia qu'il ya des gens qui
deviennent des inutiles comme dire ils
sont noyés
je mâche technologique dans un pays où
il n'a pas de droit de vote
j'aimerais mieux pas être à leur place
que parce que les patients avec en place
on va pas s'en débarrasser d'acteur mais
c'est extrêmement facile vendredi de mai
ce qu'ils on en parle beaucoup quand on
veut se débarrasser d'une partie de la
population
vous trouvez des excuses pour le faire
je pense que le film noir
si elle veut se débarrasser partie de la
population de dix minutes il pour faire
de l'optimisation elle aura aucun
problème et trouvé une bonne excuse pour
faire sa première partie du livre
si vous et si vous êtes du genre à ne
pas arriver à dormir la nuit parce que
chez les films à nous envahir pour
prenez le taureau par les cornes et des
esprits vous apprendrez beaucoup de
choses pour la macération des plus
clairs fugace et c'est intéressant parce
que c'est vraiment un livre parce qu'il
ya très peu de livres qui parlent
vraiment bien de ce qui se passe en
chine
je joue beaucoup et ça c'est un type qui
s'appelle un peu particulier passé il ya
beaucoup travaillé et vécu en chine et
beaucoup travaillé et vécu dans la
silicon valley les leaders il peut faire
le lien entre les deux c'est maintenant
la deuxième partie du livre il par la
malchance de cette histoire de chômage
technologique d'idées que avec la déjà
ratifié compagnie n'essaie pas de faire
des paniers surtout toujours parler en
termes de probabilités mais ce qu'ils
veulent c'est bien s'est il est assez
probable que grosse partie de la
population soient chassés du marché du
travail par motif d'automatisation bien
sûr une partie d'entre elles va
retrouver des niveaux plus forcément
mais après on a de bonnes raisons de
penser que ça risquerait en outre qu'il
ya une grande probabilité pour que tout
le monde ne retrouve pas du boulot et
que certains soient vraiment exclu du
marché il quels que soient les efforts
de bonne volonté qui fasse ou alors ça
se passerait pas instantanée mais ça
pourrait devenir hors de plus en plus
dur c'était un peu le cas aujourd'hui
par exemple j'ai camani sont un peu au
rsa qui allait voir un peu se battre
pour faire des captures mais pour ce
beau mano ils étaient plusieurs
candidats et en gros ils vont prendre
celui qui est beaucoup plus simple parce
que même pour des petits boulots simple
ou double soit obligé d'avoir un gros cv
pour avoir un peu moins pas de
qualification a priori c'est un peu
choquant et je prends responsable en
pire et aux pierres progressivement pas
au mieux progressivement au pire
brutalement ouais axe entre 6 et donc du
coup à ses blessures il faut le faire
tout notre possible pour
on est jean complémentaire de dia dans
le sens où déjà quitte à former des gens
ça sert à rien de les former à des trucs
qui vont être remplacés par une
intelligence artificielle ce serait une
perte de temps donc faut il former à des
trucs qui seront pas de préférence pas
remplacés par des veilleurs officielle
que ce soit en termes d'éducation à
l'école ou bien de l'information
contenue mais et mais il pense aussi qu
il faut clairement envisager le scénario
ce ne sera pas suffisant et une large
part de la population pourra être
exclues du marché du travail ce qui
pourrait avoir des conséquences sociales
dramatiques ne serait ce qu'en termes de
tension sociale
donc oui oui oui il y aura lui il disait
qu'il est pas trop favorable aux oranje
ni de place pour parce que ça c'est un
sujet intéressant c'est qu'apparemment
il ya là si on donnait envie de base à
pomoy aucun problème à savoir comment
faire c'est vrai qu'elle savait
apparemment il y avoir un argument c'est
qu'il ya des gens qui sont aux petits
soins au chômage bons qui donnent
allocations chômage qui prennent pour
manger mais pas sans journée à déprimer
à boire de l'alcool à regarder la télé
est à nouveau plus de façon plus moderne
à scrollé sur les réseaux sociaux mais
de manière toxiques où ils vont
s'énerver sur de plus en plus des trucs
et se sentait plus en plus simple parce
que les autres y sont des supers mac ans
à des gens qui au moins par défaut vont
avoir mauvaise ou mal utilisé sur une
base effectivement comme d'idron
alexandre
des prix mais bon j'ai cité dans la
journée que ea après la laine le point d
accord que je peux avoir c'est que moi
je pense que même si peut-être qu'il ya
des gens qui disent on va voir ce
problème de façon irrémédiable et c'est
triste je pense qu'il y en a une énorme
marge d'amélioration possibles en on
parle beaucoup de reformer les gens je
pense qu'on peut faire c'est former les
gens à bien utiliser leur temps parce
que c'est vrai qu'on n'a aucun cours de
ça à l'école et au final ce que beaucoup
de gens font leur boulot la journée et
puis ils rentrent chez eux le soir et
ils savent pas trop quoi faire et puis
même si c'est pas trop mon travail ma il
n'aime pas trop leur temps de loisirs
non plus parce qu'ils savent pas quoi en
faire
il proposait un truc baky qui ce fait
plus ou moins déjà taiwan donc c'est
parce que dans les pays dans les pays d
it ratera trois avancées
technologiquement que comme le japon ils
ont beaucoup de vieux parce qu'en plus
il préférant éviter donc ils doivent
apprendre à gérer verrez les vieux il ya
plein de deux vieux qui apparemment à
taïwan ils font une espèce de travaux
d'intérêt général dont kim et un gilet
[Musique]
rétro politique qui nous fera que ses
ingénieurs et ils vont faire des trucs
faire des visites bénévolat par exemple
guidée des gens dans des villas des
musées ou dans des parcs nationaux et
des aveugles traversée dans des petits
trucs socialement utile qu'on va pas
forcément financer de base si on est
sous pression économique mais qui est
bien s'occuper des enfants
ce qu'on appelle le peu à peu près midi
le caire voici qu'on sait pas très bien
automatisé qui donnant pas beaucoup
forcément de qualification mais qui
améliorent la qualité de société pendant
que maman cc c'est mieux s'il ya plus de
gens pour s'occuper des enfants que si
on n'a pas beaucoup donc la voyez
c'était plus de payer les gens à ne pas
faire voir battant par semaine
garantir à ce qui sera un peu plus qu'un
revenu de base de petit smic de petites
pensions retraites pour pour faire
vingtaine d'heures par semaine ces deux
travaux qu intérêts généraux pour
lesquelles ont finalement sarah commet
pas de trucs à faire ce soit ça soit
essayer sur de se reformer de façon
utile pour un nouveau métier de liens
sachant que parfois la chance car gens
ne peuvent pas se reformer parce que ils
sont sous pression économique pourrait
se reformer mais ça prendrait par
exemple deux ou trois ans à prendre pour
un nouveau métier qui sont des enfants à
nourrir ils peuvent pas du coup ça
permettrait au vent qui pourrait se
reformer ne peuvent pas de réciter
m'accueille de le faire hockey sur glace
quelque chose d'autre à rajouter au cdc
va super bien merci je pense que ces
trois livres aussi me j'ai eu d'autres
oiseaux mais ce qui donne mais on voit
ces trois là je les rends compte aussi
très vivement très intéressant je pense
que ça montre c'est notre truc
intéressant c'est que du coup pour
parler de transhumanisme pour réfléchir
aux propos du fonctionnalisme il ya des
livres sur le transhumanisme et c'est
aussi très intéressant d'aller chercher
des idées à gauche à droite pour essayer
de le structurer sa réflexion globale en
tout cas c'est un truc que j'ai c'est de
promouvoir à travers ce podcast
notamment essayer d'avoir plus de
discussions interdisciplinaires en tout
cas merci beaucoup à alexandre pour
cette interview vous pouvez retrouver
alexandre sur sa chaîne alex techno prog
et alexandre chevrier
alexandre techno prog dont il ya
beaucoup de vidéos affection sur mieux
débattre sur les valises à nice mme en
tout cas merci d'être venus et à la
prochaine fois sur probablement